owning was making noises it was getting
ready for us to enter it to take us off
planet and you know you get a chance to
take a picture sometimes you you stand
there you look there you think about all
the training you've done all the
preparation and again all the people
that have helped you get there and it's
just a solemn amazing moment for all of
us and there's another amazing drone
shot Lauren you explain this a little
bit earlier about kind of how how SpaceX
brings the rocket and capsule vertical
now that we see it can you kind of
explain that again for folks who maybe
miss that yes of course
dragon is actually processed a few miles
down the road at area 59 or dragon land
as we like to call it we then put it on
a truck and drive it all the way to the
hangar where the rocket is and so what
will happen is will then break we call
it break over where the vehicles up
vertical we'll turn it sideways because
the rocket is being processed sideways
or horizontal into the hangar lift it
made it to Falcon nine and then roll up
those hangar doors and essentially pull
the vehicle in the transporter erector
which is the big white trust structure
that you see there all the fluid lines
electrical lines and everything are
connected to their vehicles via the TE
transporter erector and they basically
roll it up those those rails you can't
really see them you've gotta see them in
the screen those are rails roll the the
entire te rocket dragon assembly up to
the very top of the pad pin it into the
pad systems and then roll it up vertical
and we are about t-minus two hours 57
minutes 44 seconds and counting in just
a couple of minutes we are expecting to
hear a formal announcement that the crew
is at the path of course we saw them
pull up and the Tesla's in there they
are it looks like they've already gotten
out of the car and they are walking up
to the elevator that will carry them all
the way up to the 255 foot level and
then they'll have a couple of steps to
get up to the level where the crew
access arm is I have the ac/dc song in
my head as I see them walking up you
know what I was I was
Jamin out - on my way in was ZZ top
sharp-dressed man oh there they are
taking taken in the sight craning to see
the top of the Falcon 9 rocket
it's 230 feet tall if you round up and
then crew dragon is another 27 feet from
the bottom of the trunk to the top of
the nosecone so if you're when you're
out there in person it's it's it's
really hard to describe just how how
large it is look at them getting excited
they're they're ready to get in the
vehicle get in the elevator and make it
to the top there's some Fahd he's
picking up foreign object debris they're
also wearing fog covers on their shoes
by the way oh really
yeah we want to make sure that they
don't you know track the outside inside
of dragon when they go in and so right
before they enter the vehicle they were
moved too far the five covers off of
their boots you take for granted you
know all just the little details like
that all of the thought and preparation
has to go into literally every single
piece of this operation
I love the makeover of Panther 9a with
the sleek black with the white ticking
in the lines and it's a it's a very
futuristic look for this iconic launch
pad and to think what's been there
before with Mercury Gemini Apollo
shuttle and now the SpaceX crew dragon
getting ready for a launch to the
International Space Station rocket fuels
still blowing through my veins and we
feel so honored to be able to launch
from here oh here they are
that's a really fast elevator yeah I
know it really zips that took them up to
255 feet in just a matter of seconds
they were moving their their fog covers
it looks like they were just maybe
checking something on his on his boot or
leg
and we should hear a call any moment
that the crew has arrived at the pad as
they make their way up the stairs and
they're headed to the crew access arm
now there's the worm again poppin you
know it oh don't worry there's a
meatball on crew dragon those white
arrows you see there are essentially
illuminating the way for anyone who's up
there to find their way to the escape
baskets in the event of an emergency
that would require them to get far away
from the rocket in the pad and it's hard
to tell from this angle but there's
actually a phone right here and I can't
tell if it's Bob or Doug that's using
the phone right now but Leah and can you
explain the significance of that it's
the same phone that was there during the
shuttle days yeah you get a chance to
talk to maybe friends or family that you
haven't had a maybe couldn't come to the
launch in this case is quite a few
people but just to have that last moment
to talk to someone before you get in the
vehicle it's a beautiful view
and went and we're watching the crew
when they're done using the phone there
we expect them to be making their way
into the crew access arm and coming up
at about t-minus 2 hours and 35 minutes
the astronauts will ingress or that's a
word we use to describe climbing into
crew Dragon and we saw Doug do it a
couple minutes early on Wednesday there
are a little bit ahead of schedule so
that that time could be a little bit
flexible but that's gonna happen with
the assistance of the suit text and they
will get strapped into their seats and
so with that coming up we're gonna head
over to Hawthorne for a preview of
what's in store for the future in space
travel Jesse thanks Marie
yeah shortly after we begin to regularly
fly NASA astronauts tune from the space
station SpaceX will also begin flying
private passengers to station and beyond
using dragon right essa is enabling up
to two private astronaut missions to
visit the station each year just as part
of our support of economy and low-earth
orbit it's one of the many Woody's
NASA's working to just open up access to
outer space for companies to manufacture
products in microgravity for any new
commercial modules in space and really
just to enable more people to be able to
explore the Stars firsthand and the more
people out there exploring the Stars the
closer we become to becoming a
multiplanetary species earlier we showed
you a first-hand look at where you would
train if you were to fly with us onboard
dragon but now let's take a peek inside
of the spacecraft itself
intuitive to know what we need to do at
any given moment in time when I think
about comfort for the astronauts it's
it's really every aspect of how you
could interact with the spaceship that
comes to mind we have three different
seat sizes we even go so far as molding
the foam around the astronauts body so
there's not any pressure points and it's
just generally a pleasurable journey to
space dragon is a spaceship that's all
about safety and reliability we designed
it to be to fault-tolerant which means
that any two things could fail so I
could lose a flight computer and a
thruster and I could still bring the
crew back home safely we also added a
launch escape system if anything goes
wrong on a sense that the crew can get
away from Falcon and get picked up
safely I've worked on dragon since since
2012 when I see dragon liftoff I think
I'm going to feel a build up of emotion
of eight years of working with some of
the best engineers and technicians
across the country that that put their
heart and mind into making this
incredible moments happen for for
everybody
all right so that was a detailed look
inside dragon here's a live look at two
astronauts about to climb right in if
you're just now tuning in you're
watching our coverage of the mission
known as demonstration mission two or
demo two two days SpaceX and NASA are
going to be sending people into orbit on
a mission to the International Space
Station from US soil for the first time
since 2011 Bob bankin and Doug Hurley
are the NASA astronauts flying today and
you can see them right there on screen
they're just right next to their ride up
into space yeah very exciting so as you
can see they have already arrived at pad
39a where Falcon 9 will lift off from at
3:22 p.m. Eastern Time today they have
ascended the tall structure already
which is next to the rocket and it's
called the fixed service structure and
also have already walked down the
corridor which is known as the crew arm
which is what they're standing in right
now that's right and as they prepare to
board dragon they have this one final
stop they're standing in right now and
that's the white room white room is
literally just the room at the end of
the crew arm that has an opening into
dragon it is the last place on planet
Earth Bob and Doug are going to be
standing before they step into Dragon
for their ride to the International
Space Station and the term the white
room was first used during NASA Gemini
missions where the room right before
entering the spaceship was painted white
and as you can see we've continued this
tradition with painting ours white as
well and on Wednesday they actually
started a new tradition by signing the
wall in the white room it's a fairly
small area that has room for the crew
and a few ground support members to
complete cargo load at t-minus 24 hours
and crew ingress at t-minus 2 hours and
35 minutes which is coming up here
shortly and ingress is how we refer to
the crew boarding dragon also inside the
white room is a movable platform that
just gets extended out to the capsule
just to make that boarding process much
smoother for the crew to climb into
dragon as you might expect it's also
environmentally controlled you can see
kind of a big seal right up against the
the side hatch and that's just done so
dragon can be open while keeping all the
dust dirt and the Florida humidity out
of the
so making sure it's pristine for the
crew and so that seals gonna stay in
place until they begin to retract it get
the arm ready to move out of the way and
by that point the hatch already be
closed and the white room also has lots
of tools in order to open the side hatch
complete crew ingress and prepare for
any contingencies or emergency that may
be encountered and right now they're
just in the white room they're getting a
final brief and you can see them with a
number of different pad technicians
everybody on that team has a specific
job some are specialists who are gonna
help Bob and Doug get connected to their
seats some are specialists with the
Dragon capsule itself or they're gonna
be responsible for closing the hatch and
we also you typically have a
photographer in there just to help kind
of capture these moments as the crew
gets ready so right now we're watching
and we can see them start to line up
there we'll see Bob or Doug Hurley go in
first and so he'll be the first one
through the capsule and he's gonna be
ingressing that's just our spaceflight
term for enter and you're gonna hear a
lot of these terms throughout the next
couple of days as they make their way up
to orbit ingress getting in egress
coming out and they're also doing that
final Fahd check making sure that the
crew don't have any foreign object
debris dust dirt anything that could
interfere with the systems on dragon
just before they get it right as Leland
and Lauren were mentioning earlier they
do have stuff on their suits to protect
from Fahd and they have fog covers on
their boots as they mentioned as well as
on their umbilical port on their suits
on schedule listening into the nets and
hearing those updates live yes once the
fog check is complete they can enter
which is happening live on your screen
right now
and as they climb into dragon they will
buckle themselves in and attach their
umbilicals to their suits and as you can
see the suit techs are there to help
them get buckled and settled into those
seats and as we mentioned earlier in the
broadcast the suits primary function is
to protect the crew in the event of a
cabin depressurization so the suits help
keep them cool as well as delivers
nitrox
in case there is a suit depressurization
as we go through this we saw Doug Hurley
go in first he's the commander for this
mission he's closest to your screen and
then Bob Jenkins just next to him and
they're gonna get some assistance from
these suit texts as they get in there
are four seats inside of dragon for
these missions and they are numbered one
through four if you're looking from the
perspective of the suit text inside the
hatch going from right to left so Doug
Hurley is in seat two
that's the commander's seat and Bob
bankin is in c3 which four crew dragons
the pilot seat obviously we don't have
anybody in seats 1 or 4 today crew
dragon is designed to carry four
astronauts though on future NASA
missions and we'll see that on crew 1
which will have three NASA astronauts
and one from our partner agency jaxa and
then directly above the crew right now
but right in front of them once their
seats get rotated are the three displays
that they'll use throughout the flight
and that just gives them insight into
all of dragon systems it allows them to
take control of the vehicle and manually
fly it which will see them do hopefully
only twice during to manual flight test
is again dragons autonomous but they can
jump in and take over if they need to as
Dan mentioned the displays are above
them right now but those seats will
rotate back for launch position so that
they can easily access those displays so
coming up next the crew will do a
contract once they're all settled in and
that's so that they can check to make
sure that they can hear Mission Control
and then after that their seats will be
rotated into position so let's check in
with John in sparker for the latest on
the health of both of those vehicle
John what's what's the status update
today we're at t-minus two hours 43
minutes and counting down for the launch
of Falcon 9 with dragon to the space
station as you see the dragon Launchpad
team has obviously arrived at the pallet
they got there shortly after t-minus
four hours open up the side hatch on
dragon got ready for the arrival of the
astronauts we saw the crew come up the
elevators walk over and enter dragon and
they're now getting situated inside the
capsule now the flight team is
monitoring data from Dragon they most
recently have completed a command and
telemetry check of the radio frequency
system on dragon through the tracking
and data relay satellite network that
looked to go well there are no issues
and work as we watch the astronauts
getting situated in their seats inside
the Dragon spacecraft the Falcon 9 team
is preparing for final checkouts and
propellant load those checkouts are due
to begin at t-minus two hours some 42
minutes from now when the launch crew
officially gets on console in the firing
room all systems on Falcon 9 are
currently go the rage continues to be
green on the support side the areas
around the pad obviously clear except
for the folks doing the entry into the
capsule air and sea space are clear we
hear helicopter go by from time to time
the big concern is weather forecast we
are continuing right now at a 50 percent
probability of violation of the weather
constraints the big concerns are going
to be the thick clouds precipitation
possibility of lightning I mentioned
earlier normally you get a strong sea
breeze from the ocean that pushes inland
and keeps the clouds from Central
Florida from building up
but today the sea breeze is fairly weak
so we expect the the thunderstorms will
get closer to launch pad we're also
checking downrange conditions if there's
a contingency splashdown of Dragon we're
looking at essentially the wave heights
lightning rain along the trajectory
right now it's marginal but it is still
we do expect that to improve slightly
during the day so fingers crossed there
that the downrange weather looks good
but right now at t-minus two hours 41
minutes as the clock continues to count
down all systems are go for launch
all right thanks John I and as we watch
Bob and Doug get buckled into their
seats I'm joined once again by SpaceX is
Jessica Jensen just to kind of walk
through everybody what made Ragan a 21st
century spacecraft so first of all
thanks for coming in today I know you
gotta come in for a launch that's always
tough walk us through again kind of
dragons life history I mean we have one
in a cleanroom pretty soon right behind
us walk us how we got to where we are
today to have Bob and Doug climbing into
that spacecraft sure so SpaceX was
founded to make life multiplanetary that
was why Elon started the company back in
2002 and but you know also when he found
that the company we were a very small
company for several years and so we had
to look for opportunities to you know
hey how do you go from being a small
company to actually putting people into
orbit so when NASA came out with the
need to fly cargo to and from the
International Space Station we jumped on
that because we said hey first not only
is carrying cargo to and from the space
station cool I bet we could actually
then fly people to the International
Space Station and hey for eight years
now we've been flying cargo yeah and
then now we are have transitioned over
into flying crew and cargo together so
that's basically been the evolution of
Dragon and it's been awesome and I know
when we see Falcon 9 we get to talk a
lot about reusability everyone is very
familiar with the first stage coming
back down and yeah how cool that looks
dragon is also designed with some
reusability in fact you've flown dragon
multiple times or you've flown dragons
multiple times to the space station
how does reusability factor into dragons
lifecycle yeah so I'll actually talk a
little bit about both because I one
thing I think everyone always thinks
about reusability and hey it saves money
or that's great but reusability actually
improves your reliability so when we get
Falcons back and when we
Dragons back either after one mission or
multiple mission we can do all these
detailed inspections on them and that's
super important because when you fly a
vehicle you can only have so many
sensors on it you can't put a sensor you
know every single inch of a rocket or a
spacecraft there's already way more than
I think anybody realized exactly but so
you know especially for rockets that
wind up in the ocean some people don't
have any idea of what they actually went
through so the fact that we get all the
hardware back we were able to inspect
literally every square inch of it and
make small design changes that actually
improve reliability for the whole fleet
so even though Bob and Doug are on a
brand new rocket and a brand new
spacecraft that those spacecraft are
actually more reliable based on the
knowledge we've learned from reusability
we've walked people through a lot of the
new systems on Dragon what are just some
of the cool things that are maybe
beneath the surface that people don't
know about with dragon so I think one of
the coolest things is the autonomous
docking system and what that is is it's
basically we have you know GPS sensors
on dragon but then we also have cameras
and imaging sensors such as a lidar on
basically the nose cone or the front
part of dragon as its approaching the
space station and all these sensors are
feeding data back to our flight computer
to say hey how far away am i from the
space station
what's my relative velocity to the space
station and then that feeds into the
flight computer which has algorithms
Rippa written by our engineers to say
okay based on how far away you are in
your rates here's how you fire the
thrusters to most effectively get to the
docking target I think that's just super
cool I mean we're all waiting for our
cars to drive ourselves to work and for
Bob and Doug that's exactly what it's
doing for them exactly and what I think
is so cool is the computer does this
just like flawlessly it's easy when I
tried to do it I failed miserably I
tried to dock drag in to the ISS three
times and I failed fourth time I got it
I will tell the public out there that on
our website we actually have a dragon
ISS simulator so you yourselves can try
and fire the thrusters you see how well
you do maybe I'm just a bad driver but I
think the flight computer does a really
good job I think we all had fun
all right well we are just starting to
hear they're gonna start up those calm
checks with Bob and Doug cd-r PLT con
checks going listen in here they are
loud and clear
yeah I'll be loud and clear core loud
and clear umbilical contract complete
standby for a ground station contract
and again we're just listening in
they're doing these comm check these
communication checks so Bob and Doug are
gonna do a series of these checkouts
with the teams on the ground both the
core here in Hawthorne and the launch
director out in Florida and they're
gonna be doing this over dragging the
ground and they're also going to be
doing it over the countdown net those
are the two main loops or nets that
you're gonna hear going out and they're
gonna be doing it through their
different communications paths we heard
them do through the teachers or the
tracking data and relay satellites those
are those primary satellites that we're
going to be used to talk to Bob and Doug
throughout their flight and to send
commands to Dragon they'll also do it
through ground stations spacex has a
worldwide network of ground out
worldwide network of ground stations
that they're able to communicate with
the vehicle and that's what we'll be
using to get video inside the cabin of
Bob and Doug on their flight up so if
you tuned in the other day this is one
of the first things that they do once
they get inside the vehicle and this is
just to make sure all the communication
systems with the Dragon spacecraft with
the suits everything are working they're
able to talk to and hear everybody on
the ground
dragon spacex contact ground stations
basic dragon loud and clear core loud
and clear ground station contact
completes and by for teachers contract
and just a reminder you're hearing the
core that's the crew operations
responsible engineer that's if you've
followed NASA missions in the past
that's the Capcom position that is this
pretty much the singular voice that's
talking to the astronauts throughout
their flight that's a position based
here in Hawthorne California and you'll
also hear dragon SpaceX contract
teachers made that dragon loud and clear
cord loud and clear teachers comm check
complete standby with contracts with MD
and LD in the launch configuration
dragon MD on counselin come check thanks
Jason mouth clear copy you loud and
clear glad to have you guys on board and
I stand by for contract on dragon
aground dragon MD dragon around come
check and B dragon loud and clear
MD loud and clear stand by for contracts
with LD dragon launch director I kept on
one call check good afternoon Mike loud
and clear I have you the same man good
afternoon
stand by for my comm check on dragon
aground Dragon SpaceX dragon the ground
table check SpaceX Dragon loud and clear
I have you the same back to Corey and
dragon SpaceX it's good this concludes
our launch configuration contracts
report when ready for seat rotation for
section 2 of 4.1 zero zero I'm gonna put
that working copy all right so all those
communications checks were done
successfully and you could even see
and it's so cool when we get these views
right inside the cabin dragon in two
decimal two we are ready for seat
rotation copy we will report when
initiating but you could see Doug early
using his right hand he has the talk
button built into the seat itself so
just again showing you all of the
different systems how the suit is
integrated into the seat and it's all
just one big circle for this whole
spacecraft so really cool to see those
comp checks live um Jessica thank you so
much for Joe walking us through some of
the really cool updates the upgrades did
you have any other cool stuff besides
let's see so I don't know if you guys
can see but we have the dragon cleanroom
here and one of the coolest things is it
is right on the main floor of our main
building so thousands of employees walk
by here all the time and get to see
dragon in its final processing before it
goes to the Cape on Wednesday the crew
one capsule was in here it looked almost
done it looks a little empty right now
but that's because that capsule went off
into our separate test facility for its
final propulsion checks so we do leak
checks and things there and we do that
in a separate facility just because it's
high pressure testing and then the
vehicle will come back here get its
final thermal protection system put on
and then it will ship off to Cape
Canaveral and get ready to launch for
astronauts to the International Space
Station
I mean what's what's it like to see it
because when you see the first initial
pressure vessel it looks nothing like
the final thing so what's it like to
just kind of watch it go through and you
just see little bits get added on and
then the next thing you know it's a
whole spacecraft yeah I mean that's what
that's what's so amazing I'm so
impressed you know when you look at a
machine you're like how does this ever
get built how do people ever do this and
it really is just step by step one piece
at a time each piece has its critical
function and you get to watch that being
built right in front of your eyes every
day when you try to work a 60-hour seat
rotation dragon copy and we just heard
the C rotations about to begin so
Jessica thank you so much cool facts
about dragon for everyone to listen in
on and we can see the seats start to
rotate now pretty soon Bob and Doug will
be in their launch configuration and
they'll be ready to go
we can see the seats slowly start to
rotate again they're in this down
position just to make it easier to climb
in and out of dragon they'll rotate to
this launch position to put their backs
a little bit more parallel to the ground
it makes taking the g-force a little bit
easier for the quraan the way uphill but
most importantly positions those
touchscreens directly in front of them
which is just their gateway into dragon
dragons SpaceX seats they're in the
launch position we're happy all right in
confirmation the seats are in the launch
position let's go down now to Gary in
Mission Control Houston where I know the
entire JSC team is standing by and ready
to see dragon take flight today over to
you Gary thanks Dan very much so great
to see good comm checks from Bob and
Doug and their seats have been rotated
into their launch position here in
Houston flight directors EBSCO ville has
polled Space Station flight controllers
and all systems are go for launch from
the space station side of things
essentially the station's prepared for
Dragon to arrive 19 hour hours after
launch Chris Cassidy has completed his
preparations for Bob and Doug to arrive
he's got a chance to view some of the
broadcast it even said they were quote
looking sharp flight controllers here
will monitor the countdown but really
it's up to the teams in Kennedy and
Hawthorne to get us to liftoff at this
point so we want to hear your comments
as we continue to countdown to launch so
let's go to the social desk now Tahira
thanks Gary so glad to hear that
polls are go at least on your end and
just hoping this weather just works out
good for today's launch
I mean people online are on the edge of
their seats we just checked numbers and
we are up to 1.1 million viewers right
now that's almost double when we checked
last time and right now we also have
Columbia South Carolina is leading the
viewership so interesting to see how
that changes let's take a broader look
at the conversation online with this
heat map of the United States now this
shows launch America mentions by state
over the past week and we have
California leading right now with the
most mentions and I'm very surprised I
really thought the Space Coast would
take it home but let
see how this changes over the course of
the broadcast and with that let's see
what y'all are posting online right now
guys I mean check out these outfits
absolutely love it
love to just see how people are making
things creative for this launch and
really making it their own putting their
personal touch on it let's take a look
at another oh we are back to the launch
America heat mention so let's see how
that changes over the course of this
broadcast but really fun to see those
photos online oh we have another space
pack guys these do not get old so please
use hashtag launch America on social
media right now it looks like we have
catched or not Boris who is ready for
his launch in the crew Dragon capsule I
just I love seeing the pet owners unite
for this mission so like I said
definitely use that hashtag we will be
looking for it during the show Murray
what's the latest at Kennedy thanks to
Hiro we are at t-minus two hours 26
minutes 47 seconds and counting from
liftoff of the Falcon 9 from the Kennedy
Space Center here in Florida carrying US
astronauts Doug Hurley and Bob Behnken
you see them right now aboard SpaceX's
crewed Ragan's spacecraft it's been a
very exciting day so far the crew has
been up since about 8 o'clock this
morning as they prepare to head to the
International Space Station as part of
this demo - mission for NASA and as we
speak the astronauts as you saw our
inside dragon air and have completed
their comm checks so now they can
communicate with the teams here on the
ground and their seats have rotated
upright - they're reclined launch
positions allowing them to see and
access the display panel and now they
are about to they initiate their their
own suit leak checks to make sure that
their seat is in proper working
condition before liftoff and in just a
little bit at about t-minus one hour 55
minutes it could happen a little bit
sooner though we're running a little bit
ahead of schedule we will see the
closeout team begin to close the side
hatch in preparation for flight and
that's gonna be one of the key visual
milestones on the timeline to liftoff
now we want to take you to a couple of
special guests we have
they are with Darrell nail at the OSB 2
viewing location
NASA Administrator Jim bridenstine and
also Kennedy Space Center Director Bob
Cabana is there with Darrell
hi Darrell hi Marie that's right we're
in the fifth floor of the operations and
support building here at the Kennedy
Space Center with a nice view of launch
complex 39 and the two men that you
mentioned are here to join me to answer
a few questions we're excited to have
them both here and they are of course
Bob Cabana the director of the Kennedy
Space Center and Jim Bryden Stein
administrator for NASA gentlemen thanks
again for making the time to be here of
course the big story right now Jim is
the weather so let's talk a little bit
about that we can see there's some
clouds building that was forecast you
took part in a weather briefing this
morning what do you know about the
weather and the decision that was made
to say hey let's let's give this another
shot today yeah so what godess last time
was the electricity in the atmosphere
and of course today there are in fact
buildups it doesn't look like there are
thunderstorms at this time but they are
expected the question is when do those
thunderstorms go away and when those
thunderstorms materialize where are they
located we are predicting about a 50/50
shot of going this time but given the
fact that we are in late May in Florida
where we have to take every shot we can
get so it's not likely that in a couple
of days it's going to be any better than
it is today so we're we are a go for
launch right now and we are hoping that
the weather will hold up we almost made
it on Wednesday and the trend is better
today than it was on Wednesday so we'll
see and I saw a forecast that said the
clearing is supposed to happen right
around three o'clock in the afternoon so
we're hoping that that lunch is at 3:20
to firing you know at the earliest three
o'clock at the latest 3:30 so depending
on when that happens will will either be
go or no-go but again we're gonna take
every shot we've got also watching the
downrange weather for potential rescue
in case there were an abort that's right
so you know we have these staging areas
when we go from the first stage to the
second stage that's a higher risk
evolution we want to make sure that in
the case
we have to exercise the launch abort at
that point that the weather is good and
of course that's off the coast of North
Carolina the big thing there is it's
great that we have a launch abort
capability the challenge is that launch
abort capability includes parachutes and
with parachutes you've got to make sure
that you've got the weather to come down
if there are thunderstorms or downburst
or high winds that's problematic for the
parachute system right and sea States as
well bouncing that capsule around in the
ocean but of course you're an astronaut
you know what it's like to hit the reset
button and do it all over again get into
the spacecraft get ready to go only to
be told no we're not gonna go today
we're gonna try it again what's that
like and then and then tell me about the
mindset as you have to kind of reset is
there do you feel less anxious you feel
more comfortable with the second time
around you know Daryl first off my last
flight we counted down to 18 seconds and
didn't go manum you get 18 seconds
you're ready
the key is you know it's a training that
we go through all the repetition that we
do we practice everything including
scrubs and just because you didn't
launch doesn't mean you don't have
something to do so you got to go through
those back out procedures it's all done
very professionally then it was out of
the vehicle and into the Astro van back
to crew quarters in it we have a
positive attitude we got a good night's
rest and we went through it again it's
just it's a matter of doing your job and
these guys are well-prepared you know
it's all part of what we do yeah they
stopped the count at 17 minutes but you
had just a few seconds and the truth is
the next night actually everything went
really better you know the weather was
bad the first time I was kind of glad we
scrubbed and we scrubbed for an issue
with the vehicle that they later sorted
out as it turned out we wouldn't had
enough' prop to rendezvous with the
Russian functional cargo block but you
know the next night it was just a
perfectly smooth launch count everything
just went like clockwork and it set the
stage for an awesome mission I think you
told the press before you walked out I
think you were over there at astronaut
crew quarters we're going today I'm
wondering though where's the source of
that confidence coming by I just got a
feeling you know you gotta have a
positive attitude you know I watched a
lot of weather down here support and
shuttle missions and I'm hoping that
those clouds over the i-95
that the Indian River keeps some west of
west of us and that stuff that's
building offshore is far enough off that
we can stay stay in an open window here
at the Cape good well we got your
positive vibe going and we appreciate
that Jim when you were down in the
astronaut crew quarters and when they
were suiting up you got a second chance
to visit with the astronauts come tell
us about that and what was their
demeanor what was their mood today so
again they seemed loose they were loose
last time they're loose this time
they're definitely ready to go they're
excited they've been wanting to go for a
long time now you know what was I'll
tell you one thing that I thought was a
little interesting is you know Bob
Behnken was making fun of Doug Hurley
because I'm Doug's last flight they
scrubbed five times before launching on
the sixth time so Bob Behnken seems to
think that Doug Hurley is the problem in
us in this case but to see them joking
about that as they're getting suited up
ready to go yes there they're there
they're trained they're ready but
they're also loose and that's good to
see because because they're gonna have
to be on their game when when we launch
these guys are pretty impressive Doug
Hurley and Bob Behnken I mean Doug
Hurley an incredible pilot Bob Behnken
he's got a PhD in mechanical engineering
flight test engineer and myself and Air
Force down boy and you're in your
assessment why are these guys the right
stuff well this is a test flight and and
you know we got we have great astronauts
that are you know chemists we have great
astronauts that are botanists we have
really talented and diverse a very very
diverse astronaut corps in general but
this is a test flight and for a test
flight what do you want you want test
pilots you want people that for a living
they have made a living flying new
things that have never been flown before
and you know Bob bankin and Doug Hurley
are the the two people that you would
want in a test flight and that's exactly
what this is Bob you're a pilot too you
want to weigh in on Doug Hurley he seems
like you know he's he's got the right
mentality customer he's a naval aviator
a Marine pilot a test pilot he's all I'm
all in he's a great guy
and and tell me a little bit about in
terms of the Kennedy Space Center right
so you've been here since 2007
right 2008 2008 sorry off by one year
2011 the Atlantis came to a wheel stop I
grew up here my dad worked for NASA my
uncle was the contractor when that wheel
stop happened the next day my uncle got
the layoff notice right 30 60 days it
was depressing we're talking about
thousands of people laid off
super-depressing Atlantis landed on a
Thursday on Friday 2000 contractors got
pink slips and walked out the door yet
they work on that vehicle that was the
best vehicle we ever flew that cleanest
that's the dedication of the workforce
here right so didn't take me back to
that time you called it a depressing
time you know the fact that the shuttle
program was something that the
government completely had ownership of
and paid for now we're moving into this
Commercial Crew which you've overseen
making that transition and tell me about
that nine years in which we made that
move obviously everybody was really
attached to the shuttle I mean it was
our history for thirty years and did an
awesome job the Hubble Space Telescope
all the satellites that deployed
building the International Space Station
but when I first got here I told
everybody the shuttle program is going
to end we got we have to start preparing
for our future and and nobody wanted
that to hear that but how many times in
your life do you get to define what you
want your future to be and we set out on
this bold goal of trying to turn KSC
into a multi-user spaceport supporting
both government and commercial
operations and I've got a very
persistent team they worked extremely
hard and through a number of agreements
you know we were able to make it happen
and this is the future commercial
spaceflight you know the administrator
says that all the time we want to
establish a commercial environment in
low-earth orbit so that we can focus on
the hard job of exploring beyond our
home planet to establish that presence
in our solar system beyond planet Earth
established a sustained presence on the
moon get to Mars establish the presence
there we can't do that if we're locked
here in low-earth orbit and Commercial
Crew with both SpaceX and Boeing that's
the beginning of a whole new era of
spaceflight all right very good a quick
question we got of course a special
guest coming back today the President of
the United States plans on being here
Jim you took him around the first time
around how did that go I think I saw a
picture on Twitter he signed some space
hardware that's right so so he took a
look at the Orion crew capsule of course
the Orion for Artemus one is ready to go
and he signed you know a piece of
hardware that will fly on the crew
capsule for Artemus two so that's kind
of and not just him but the first lady
and the vice president and the second
lady they all signed it so so their
names are gonna fly around the moon on
Artemis 2 which is exciting but I just
want to give Colonel Cabana
a compliment here because he did bring
this spaceport through a very difficult
time and now it is a a multi-use
spaceport and we do have commercial and
we have in fact even international
launches here and now we're going to
have commercial crew launches bob has
done a wonderful job transforming this
spaceport that's why we're doing
Commercial Crew NASA wants to be one
customer of many customers we want to
have numerous providers that are
competing on cost innovation safety
driving down costs increasing access but
even better today when I took this job
just a few short years ago you know our
budget at NASA was around 19 billion
dollars the budget requests that
President Trump gave us for next year is
25 billion dollars we are in a great
great position because the president is
committed to space exploration of course
he's committed to the space force we
haven't had this much support for space
since john f kennedy and we've got
bipartisan support everybody wants to
see the Artemis program be successful
everybody wants to see not just the next
man but the first woman on the moon and
that's what we're building here that's
Cuba the key to it all is that
bipartisan support and of course what
the work that Bob's been doing here you
can see the commercial activity all
around this place we're gonna get to
some questions on social media real
quick that are you know our audience
wants to find out so the first question
is from James on Twitter and he asks
what is the hardest part of going to
space we're gonna have to give that
question to Bob well they're you know
nothing's hard if you prepare for it and
what we are afraid of is a is stuff we
don't have knowledge about and that's
what we do when we learn how to be
astronauts we train
okay you spent a long time as an
astronaut candidate learning you spend a
long time preparing for a mission for an
International Space Station mission
training around the world on all the
different modules and everything you
know it's like two and a half years of
training before you get on orbit for
that time to actually do your work so
I'd have to say the hardest part is the
preparation for it but you are so
prepared when you go you just have total
confidence you know that you are very
well trained for what you're going to do
you have an outstanding team on the
ground supporting you and that is so
important to have that ground support as
you climb into that vehicle you know
that they have done their very best to
ensure your safety and in a successful
mission but after that it's a piece of
cake except no simulator on earth can
prepare you for what those guys are
gonna feel it's better than a catch that
off in your career I believe it maybe
one day I'll get to try the
commercialization effort means we want
everybody to be able to fly into space
absolutely that's a great point about
preparation because that's not the
highly visible part the launch is and so
it's good to know that all that
preparation leads to that confidence by
the way just an update operationally
they're getting ready to close the hatch
door you can see on your screen there
the the workers there are getting ready
to get that closed and working on
working on that right there with Doug
Doug Hurley and Bob bacon on the inside
of crew dragon our next question is from
Malthus on Twitter and he asks what kind
of operations will the astronauts do
between the liftoff and docking with the
International Space Station I know you
pay a lot of attention Jim to the
operations especially if this mission
but what do you know about that so
there's a number of things the first
thing that they have to do is of course
we've got a number of burns to get in
phase with the International Space
Station we've got some boost burns as
well we're talking about you know
operating the rocket engine to to get in
alignment with the space station but
I'll tell you the biggest thing that we
need the astronauts to do once they get
on orbit and before they dock is rest we
need them to eat we need them to rest we
need them to be prepared for that
docking once they are in the range of
the International Space Station they're
going to start maneuvering the
spacecraft themselves not
automatic but they're gonna do it
themselves they are in fact test pilots
and as test pilots they will test fly
this vehicle to make sure that it
operates as advertised and of course
then they will dock with the
International Space Station and a unique
capability here is its automatic
rendezvous and automatic docking and so
we're gonna be able to see that for the
first time as well that's going to be
exciting to see thank you for sharing
that with us
Jim Brian Stein administrator of NASA
Bob Cabana director of the Kennedy Space
Center thank you both for joining us and
we're gonna send it back to Murray in
the studio all right thanks a lot Darryl
and mr. Brydon Stein and mr. cabana for
joining us you can see some clouds
starting to gather over launch complex
39a we're keeping a close eye on weather
again 50 50 percent chance of launching
today we just got to see what the
weather's gonna do a little bit ago we
heard the crew complete their comm
checks live on the air we saw their
seats rotate that helps get them into a
little bit more comfortable position for
the g-forces during launch and more
importantly it helps them be in a better
position to interact with the screens in
front of them they completed their suit
leak checks we saw during the interview
just a few minutes ago the hatch begin
to close and so inside the white room
there the pad closeout team is in there
I'm still doing some work that that
hatch closes you know it's not as simple
as just closing a car door there's a
process to seal it and check it and make
sure that everything is sealed properly
right Lauren yeah that's correct if they
haven't already started one thing that
will be coming up next is the leak check
what they'll do is they'll attach a
piece of ground support equipment they
don't have it in their hands right now
so it looks like it hasn't started yet
there it is you can see it there the
closeout number number five it's already
attached to the side hatch mechanism and
what they'll do is they're essentially
checking for the leak rate and they'll
hold pressure there for a few minutes
and then track that change in pressure
over time to make sure that it's within
bounds making sure that you don't have
any issues with those o-rings there that
are holding that pressure
and so once they complete that leak
check they will then do what is the
called the installation or the final
installation of the s pepper side
pressure equalization plug that's
basically a plug that once the capsule
splashes down what you'll do is actually
remove that and what it does is equalize
this pressure across the hatch so once
that thing is plugged in you know that
everything is super tight and that you
shouldn't have any leaks on orbit one of
the other things that I think is pretty
cool about Dragon you can kind of see
them on the edges there are some of the
windows I know that dragon started out
as car it was cargo dragon you have your
cargo version and before you moved on to
the crew Dragon version but you even had
windows on the cargo version can you
explain kind of why that was yeah the
very first cargo dragon that we ever had
that we ever launched had a window over
the hatch over the side hatch and the
reason we did that is we always
envisioned dragon to ultimately be a
crewed vehicle so even in the beginning
for the first the very first vehicle we
ever made which carried didn't even
really care as much cargo we put that
window there and it to us symbolizes
what dragons purpose has been all along
you know taking those steps starting off
with the the CRS program and resupplying
the space station with with experiments
and and food and crew provisions for the
astronauts on boards and now putting our
own astronauts as astronauts in our own
vehicle it's that natural progression of
what we were aiming for the whole time
and Leland what's your take on the
touchscreen technology we saw a little
bit about that obviously this is a very
different kind of look than what we saw
during Space Shuttle we know it's the
future I mean we had our LCD displays
and we had lots of buttons to press and
you know valves and switches and I think
this this new technology will allow us
to get through procedures much more fat
you know much much faster because we had
no paper flight data file that we're
having to turn to different pages and
get to things and I think this will make
it much more efficient to go through
your functions in your pursue
with the touchscreens and I think you
know having the gloves being able to you
know touch the screens and work within
the gloves everything's kind of sleek
and efficient you know there's not a lot
of wires and things hanging off and
there are new boards you can see there
are new boards on their left knees so
that's for some extra little notes and
things there's some commentary we are
ready for the briefing when you are
ready of coffee and we just heard
confirmation on the loops that the hatch
is closed so that is a little bit ahead
of schedule we are motivated to go today
okay on the weather we still have some
rain showers moving through the area but
we do have a reasonable opportunity
today so we are proceeding into the
account we are going to take a look at
both pad and ascent track weather at
t-minus one hour and thirty minutes and
the next decision point will be prior to
prop load okay we copy and on the
vehicle health front both f9 and dragon
health remains nominal with no items
nope
so we just heard the weather is still
iffy thank you
the weather is still iffy concludes the
post ingress brief report when ready for
contracts with Falcon 9 operators we are
ready for the f9 operator copy expect
that shortly
so when we hear that chatter picked back
up we're going to quiet right down so
that you can listen in to that along
with us but we just heard them
discussing the weather briefly still
keeping an eye on that but the next
decision point is going to be before
prop load so we're gonna press forward
for now and then reevaluate on before
they start fueling the rocket but in the
meantime it sounds like Falcon 9 and
crew Dragon are healthy so the vehicle
is in good shape right it sounds like
kind of a little bit of a repeat from
Wednesday that were just keeping an eye
on the weather at this point you can see
on their left legs well in that previous
American spacex contracts with after
nine you can expect it in about one to
two minutes dragons ready alright on
their left legs there they have the
satchels that are strapped to their legs
inside are some crew provisions
including these tablets that you see
that they have displayed there you say
Lauren those are tablets versus just me
Boyd said you can write on tablets or
inside for the inside okay okay
and so when would they pull those
tablets out to use them during the
mission Wow yeah while in orbit okay and
I don't know if it's coming if the
background noise is coming through
over-the-air but we hear the rain really
picking up outside the studio here so
kind of wondering if Bob and Doug are
hearing the sounds of the rain clouds
opening up over the pad looks like
they're it's still kind of patchy out
there but again we were following some
thunderstorms that look like they may be
making their way over here it it kind of
looks like it's raining from that view
it's kind of it's a little bit hard to
tell
through the haze
all right lunch launch is now just over
two hours away
so here you are there with the social
teams now that the hatch is closed and
the rains picking up and all kinds of
exciting things are going on right now
as we count down and get into the last
two hours of the count I bet things are
getting pretty interesting on social
media hey Lauren I mean yes they are so
many different things are going on right
now and I think people online are just
wondering what's gonna happen with
today's mission
I have TweetDeck open right now and it
is just scrolling with the conversation
of people around the nation talking
about today's launch attempts we also
just checked viewership and we are now
up to 1.4 million people watching this
live broadcast so really hope things
look good with weather and on that note
let's take a look of some of the things
being said on Twitter right now so it
looks like we just have some more future
astronauts I really love seeing the
young generation just getting mobilized
getting excited about today's mission
looks like we've also got some Godspeed
and safe travels for both astronauts
today really do wish them the best of
luck on the second attempt hope it
happens some throwback photos all from
people visiting NASA sinners and also
just let's do this I love this can-do
attitude and I just love seeing that
people are still keeping the energy
alive for today's launch so there were
obviously some disappointing reactions
to Wednesday's scrub but let's take a
look at how people are getting excited
for today's attempt let's roll
[Music]
I mean how fun is that video I think I
will definitely have to attempt the worm
after this but just really glad to see
everyone in good spirits leading into
today's second launch attempt and I
really hope everybody will have
something to smile about and with that
let's head back to Lauren Lori thanks to
here it looks like people are pretty
stoked about today's attempt please
continue
to join the conversation by using the
hashtag launched America across all the
social media channels yeah I love seeing
I really love seeing the little kids get
excited I know my my three-year-old is
super excited she's got an astronaut
sleeping bag and she loves to climb in
it yeah it's the the body of the bag is
a spacesuit and then the head is empty
where they where the pillow is so when
she gets inside looks like she's got a
spacesuit on so she loves it that's the
inspiration for that next generation of
explorers gonna take Doug and Bob's
place one day and I think we have some
people out there that are so interested
in our conversation about the worm and
the meatball that they've created
something called the worm ball okay I
was checking my email during back as you
like I emailed you guys the worm ball
and I was like what is this I don't I'm
having a hard time seeing it but what is
the worm ball so it's a it's a NASA
meatball which is you know what it
should be yes okay look okay there it is
thank you
so they took the angular NASA logo and
put in the worm inside of the meatball
can you can you live with that Lauren
you know what that's a beautiful
compromise I'll take it and there is
another live look at launch complex 39a
and we have had the opportunity to share
with you a lot about the SpaceX crew
dragon sitting on top of Falcon nine a
lot about the crew themselves and the
significance of today as the official
return we hope of human launch
capability to American shores but we
would be remiss if we did not explain
why this pad 39a is hallowed ground
[Music]
many of nasa's story missions began
their daring journey from the exact same
spot on earth launch complex 39a at the
kennedy space center this massive
structure of steel and concrete has
cradled rockets and guided each on their
fiery ascent to space for over 50 metres
there can be no launch without a launch
pad and this hallowed ground has a
history greater than any other having
evolved and been reshaped for each new
era of spaceflight it's alive with a
heartbeat as strong as the first
Launchpad 39a came to life under the
direction of project engineer Harry may
as NASA ramped up its efforts to achieve
an unprecedented calling why some say
the I choose this and they may well ask
my climb in 1962 earthmoving machines
sculpted its massive pyramid base to a
height of 40 feet then concrete was
poured to hold it in place to launch the
world's first moon rocket engineers cut
a flame trench nearly the length of two
football fields down the middle of the
mound it was in line with heat-resistant
bricks to deflect seven and a half
million pounds of a birth rattling
thrust first felt on Apollo 8 less than
a year later Apollo 11 launched from pad
39a and hundreds of millions of people
around the world watched as it landed on
the moon
three days later nearly a decade after
this Apollo era 39a again took center
stage with a new one-of-a-kind
spacecraft this space shuttle billions
of pounds of additional steel for
service structures transformed the look
but not the purpose human spaceflight
in all 82 space shuttles blasted off
from 39a until the very last day - ten
nine eight one zero and liftoff the
final liftoff of Atlantis shoulders of
the Space Shuttle America will continue
the bridge with the fleet retired
demolition crews removed the shuttle era
hardware to clear the way for NASA's
monumental decision to lease this
historic launch site to the private
company SpaceX today it's sleek and
modern design supports a family of
rockets that has advanced the commercial
age of American spaceflight now 50 years
after it first sent humans to the moon
[Music]
this historic spaceport stands ready for
the next wave of human exploration
[Music]
and we're looking live again at pad 39a
we're looking at the pad closeout team
you can identify them by their numbers
there and we heard confirmation of the
hatch being closed just a few minutes
ago so again things a little bit ahead
of schedule
when I say ahead of schedule I don't
mean the launch time is changing I just
mean on some of the specific milestones
in the timeline those times are a little
bit flexible but that launch window
remains instantaneous at 3:22 this
afternoon
and Leland you know we just saw a piece
about the history of pad 39a Asian all
stations chief engineer and cat found
one for comm check with the crew we're
gonna pause for that contract a good
nine guidance navigation and control
dragon GNC on countdown one contact GNC
dragon we have Devon clear GNC loud and
clear stand by for comm check by the
propulsion engineer dragon problem
countdown one concert top dragon loud
and clear problems and clear stand by
for contact with the avionics engineer
dragon avionics on countdown one comm
check avionics dragon loud and clear
avionics loud and clear stand by for
contact by ground segment engineer
dragon ground segment icons on long Tong
six ground segment dragon loud and clear
gurgling loading please stand by for Tom
check for lost control dragon launch
control and countdown one Tom check
Hantz control dragon loud and clear lost
control loud and clear stand by for
contract by the chief engineer
dragon chief engineer on countdown one
konschak chief engineer dragon we've got
some loud and clear Bala chief engineer
loud and clear this completes the Falcon
9 responsible engineer context and we
just saw a thumbs up from Doug Hurley we
listened to a series of comms comms
checks there and so everything chief
engineer on dragon the ground and clear
on dragon the ground
loud and clear well good luck and let's
see if the rain clears up that sentiment
is shared by all here copy that
so Bob and Doug along with the launch
teams and all of the rest of America
hoping the rain clears up here but as
far as context go everything sounded
pretty normal pretty nominal there so
we're just waiting on the weather to
clear up but again there's a live look
at launch complex 39a the site of 82
Space Shuttle missions where they began
and of course Apollo the first mission
to the moon Apollo 11 lifted off from
39a and Leland you were just five years
old when that happened she's back there
Orion Lauren I was five and I was the
antenna engineer during the broadcast I
was the kid standing behind the
black-and-white Sylvania television
holding the rabbit ears and my dad said
move to the left
look to the right and I was trying to
look around the television to see what
was going on but I said no no stay there
so I never actually saw the actual
landing on the moon Neil and Buzz
walking on the moon and the next day all
the friend my friends in my community
were like yeah you gonna be an astronaut
we just had this momentous thing I said
no I didn't see it I want to be Arthur
Ashe because Arthur Ashe trained five
blocks down the street where I grew up
and my dad talked about us his
excellence is perseverance is
athleticism and so it wasn't until I got
to NASA working as an engineer at NASA
Langley that a friend of mine said you'd
be a great astronaut and I'm just
laughed at him and I didn't feel the
application out but another friend of
mine got in and Charlie Kamara and I
said if he can become an astronaut I can
become so I applied the next year and I
got in in the 1998 class and I think
about this again storied legacy pad 39a
I was there in 2008 and 2009 space
shuttle Atlantis the last one they came
in with Doug and the rest of the crew
and it's just an amazing time see this
new era with Lauren with your SpaceX
crew dragon about to take off I never
heard that story it's it's so cool that
you know you do have a lot of these kids
that are watching today who have never
seen a flight a human spaceflight from
KSC before
and this is their first time and I'm
trying to remember back you know I grew
up in the shuttle era and I grew up in
Los Angeles and I remember sometimes
when the shuttle would land at Edwards
Air Force Base you'd hear those sonic
booms in school and and we all just knew
oh that's the Space Shuttle it was just
the thing we just knew about that and it
didn't make me sad that there's a like
an entire generation of kids who didn't
grow up with that experience and I'm
just so proud that you know today
hopefully we get to provide that for
kids and hopefully have more and more of
these launches to the point where it
becomes routine hopefully never boring
but routine and there's talent in every
zip code to have to make sure that every
kid is has the opportunity to do these
types of things if they believe in
themselves and we give them the right
tools that they can use to be in STEM
fields and you know we have a very
diverse group of people up here working
together and get Bob and Doug off safely
and I think more people that see this
type of diversity will have a chance to
say I can do that too absolutely and you
know we have a lot of kids watching
today and we have an opportunity to hear
from another really awesome role model
especially for the little girls in the
audience so we want to throw it over to
Gary in Houston to talk to a very
special astronaut standing by there hi
Gary
hi Marie I have the distinct pleasure of
being joined by one of NASA's
record-setting astronauts and a recent
resident aboard the space station
Christina cook Christina thank you for
joining us it's great to be with you
today
Christina we're coming up on 20 years of
continuous human presence on the
International Space Station and you were
one of those humans what's it like to
see a new milestone like this launch
unfold after so much history already
you're right so much history indeed and
it's just been great to watch all unfold
I think for me the most exciting thing
is how NASA is not only innovating in
what we do it's you know exploring the
universe pushing the boundaries getting
knowledge on the space station bringing
it back to earth for benefits here but
in how we do it we're innovating in the
implementation of those goals and of our
mission and what that means is that
bringing in the private sector bringing
in a commercial space at
me for low-earth orbit I mean space is
going to be more accessible and more
innovative and it's just an awesome new
era of history to be able to witness you
hold the record for the longest single
stay by a female astronaut in space
what's it like living aboard for so long
well it is truly a privilege every
single day I have to I have to say it's
a beautiful thing to look down on the
earth and to be able to kind of
contribute to a space program that you
yourself have held in such high regard
your entire life I would say that the
biggest challenge going into sort of
those longer times is remaining vigilant
the engineers make it so easy to live on
board the space station sometimes you
forget you're actually surrounded by
such a hostile environment so remaining
vigilant both day to day to have that
appreciation then that you wake up with
every day and then also being vigilant
knowing that things could take a turn
for the worst at anytime and you have to
be ready to react to that so it's a
great privilege but it also comes with
great responsibility you came to NASA
after the days of the shuttle program
and you flew on the Russian Soyuz what
does it mean to have this private
capability to fly astronauts to the
station well I think it's just a great
innovation in terms of our partnerships
you know when we started out it was
individual countries pursuing suspects
pleurae ssin we brought in the
International aspect of it and now we're
really folding in that commercial aspect
bringing the innovation of all of our
American industrial power and
recognizing that the more partnerships
we have the more accessible the more
innovative Space Exploration can be so
it's an awesome time and it brings with
it so much more capability into the
program as well so it's not only how
we're doing it but it's what it brings
we're looking forward to having this
transportation from private companies
how does it help you do your job in
space you know I think one concept that
we have in NASA for safety and to
mitigate risk is called dissimilar
redundancy and here now we're bringing
up a sole second way of getting crew to
the International Space Station and
getting cargo last minute cargo so we're
increasing how much science we can do
onboard the space station by twofold
we're increasing how we can you know our
options for getting items up stowage
items supplies provisions science
experiments so we're really just banking
on the extra
doesn't see to make the programs that
much more robust we're watching Bob and
Doug go through the final phases of
preparing for this launch what's going
through your mind so close to liftoff
it's such a great day indeed you know
it's interesting because I think it's
not so much what is going through your
mind but what's not going through your
mind you know you're not thinking about
all the things could go wrong you're
thinking about enabling success by doing
what you've been trained to do one of
the things we have is that on launch day
astronauts are sometimes the most calm
people in the room and I found that to
be true on my launch day too I think
it's kind of this career culmination of
everything you've learned everything
you've dreamed of and you know that it's
coming together in that day and that
you're gonna finally do what you're
prepared to do execute the mission and
it just really brings a sense of calm
and readiness NASA astronaut Christina
Cooke always an honor to hear from you
thank you great to be with you
well once Bob and Doug arrived at the
station NASA astronaut Chris Cassidy
will be ready to welcome them on board
so an anticipation of their launch he
had this message for them hello everyone
I'm astronaut Chris Cassidy commander of
expedition 63 onboard the International
Space Station flying 250 miles above the
earth like you I'm excited about today's
launch and the possibilities it will
bring to America into the world but also
I'm very excited that two close friends
will be arriving and joining the crew I
had the privilege of flying with Doug
Hurley on both of our first Shuttle
missions back in 2009 together we came
to the International Space Station and
helped construct the amazing facility
that it is today although this will be
my first mission with Bob it was my
honor to follow him as a chief of the
office when he left back in 2015 to
begin training for this amazing mission
personally I've been very fortunate to
fly two different spacecraft
launching from America on the shuttle
and most recently launching from
Kazakhstan in the Soyuz but I can't tell
you how exciting it is to know that
we're once again launching Americans
from the coast of Florida and finally
here's a story I'd like to share with
you back in 1981 John Young and Bob
Crippen monster on space shuttle
Columbia the very first space shuttle
flight marking the last time we flew
Americans on a brand-new vehicle with
them they flew an American flag
representing America's technical prowess
30 years later that same flag was flown
to the International Space Station this
flag remains here today waiting for Bob
and Doug
[Music]
our flag means so many things for our
country and this small piece of America
represents what we'll be able to achieve
together we'll never stop exploring and
so Bob and Doug can take this very
special flag home to earth where it
awaits its next journey to the cosmos in
a few years if birthday Ryan crew will
take this flag with it around the moon
all of this starts today
I'll be watching outside the window
along with everyone else in America and
around the world I can't wait to look
out the window and see my friends on
close approach go Falcon 9 go dragon and
go Bob and Doug I'll see you soon and
there again is a live look at launch
complex 39a at Kennedy Space Center in
Florida or we are t-minus one hour 41
minutes 58 seconds and counting
from liftoff of the Falcon 9 rocket
carrying crew dragon with astronauts Bob
bank Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley
strapped inside we can see some
raindrops on the screen there it looks
like rain coming down at the pad but
we're still monitoring weather and it
sounds like there's going to be another
decision point before they start fueling
the Falcon 9 rocket which is scheduled
to happen at about t-minus 35 minutes so
we just heard a little bit about where
they're headed if the weather cooperates
today to the International Space Station
Leland you've been there twice and I
know just from what you've told us it's
it's this Leviathan in space and the
sight of so much important work and
partnerships happening right Chris
Cassidy's up there floating in the
Columbus laboratory that I installed or
our team of us installed on sts-122 and
I think about you know using this
robotic arm that was made in Canada the
European Space Agency built the Columbus
laboratory and my job was to use that
arm and attach it to the International
Space Station and as it was getting
closer and closer the motion just
stopped and I'm like what is going on
and therefore ready to laugh indicators
that have a very slight spring force
that I was moving so
slowly with the hand controller the
translational hand controller that that
that spring for stalled out the motion
and Peggy Whitson was behind me and she
said Leland whether some commentary
weather update I think go ahead then hey
Doug we're still waiting for a weather
update expected at eighteen Zulu
therefore the next assessment will be
closer to the propellant load time we
are currently no go and launch weather
but we are showing an expected clear of
eighteen thirty do this okay Raphael
thanks for the update so we just heard
if if they were to launch right now the
weather would be no-go however it sounds
like there may be an opportunity if the
weather clears as it sounds like they
expect it may so again we're gonna we're
gonna keep listening as we continue
talking if we start to hear any kind of
chatter especially if it's about the
weather we're gonna do our best to quiet
down so that we don't step on that and
everyone can hear it along with us but
Leland you were just talking about the
work on station and and Peggy Whitson
was getting ready to tell you something
so the Columbus laboratory is stalled
out is about to be attached and there
are 10,000 people waiting their job
security depended on me installing this
thing properly right and Peggy said
Leland push just a little bit harder on
the hand controller and all for ready to
laugh indicators went green and I was
like yes and that was our primary
mission objective but that paled in
comparison to what happened next Peggy
invited us over to dinner in the Russian
segment and we had this meal with people
from all over the world Russian German
French African American Asian American
this diversity that we talked about
earlier were up there breaking bread at
17,500 miles per hour while listening to
sha dais smooth operator
[Music]
actually changed the song to from smooth
operator to arm operator so you see and
Leland you actually we were in another
tape segment when you got a text from
Drew Feustel can you can you share that
with us yeah drew voice those good
friend just sent me a text saying that I
the families say hello to all who are
watching and thank the nation in the
world for their support and interest and
Chris Ferguson just actually sent me a
text see was the commander on sts-135
and one of my classmates from the 1998
class and he says where to go Scott
speed on crew dragon it's great to hear
those words of support thank you guys
for watching everybody following along
at home I mean the the Cova 19 situation
has been just a just a tough time for
people stuck inside home schooling their
kids still trying to do their jobs and
so it's it's really cool to be able to
to watch this happening and we see the
pad closeout team it looks like they're
getting ready or that like they've left
the the white room and they've already
come down the crew access arm so they
are getting ready to leave the pad now
and we are going to go now to the
operations and support building to where
Darryl nail is standing by with NASA's
chief of staff to talk to us a little
bit about some of NASA's ambitions
beyond the International Space Station
and its work with the Commercial Crew
program Darryl
yeah that's right we're here in the
mission briefing room at the top of
operations and support building here
where there's a lot of important people
that are gathering to watch the launch
here and one of those peoples not me by
the way one of those people that is
important is Gabe Sherman NASA's chief
of staff we appreciate you being here
hey thanks for having me Darryl you got
kind of the insight of what's coming
down the pike here at NASA so of course
today is Commercial Crew and we're
focused on that seeding the commercial
market but what's off in the horizon for
NASA well I'll just tell you it's an
incredibly exciting time to be at NASA
and you know this I mean you're here
every day but whatever you think about
what we're do
with Commercial Crew you know in the
horizon I in July we're launching Mars
perseverance which is just gonna be an
incredible incredible thing for us you
look at the end of this year you know
SLS the largest rocket in the world is
going through testing right now going
through green run testing and and we're
hoping maybe by the end of the year we
could even get it right out here to the
Cape which would be just an incredible
achievement for our team so there's no
shortage of things to be excited about
it NASA right now it feels like
everything is really starting to happen
here recently with everything that you
just mentioned and if we get that first
Artemis launch that could be right
around the corner as well you know we're
looking at I think late 2021 is what
we're looking for and so you think about
SLS potentially moving through up from
the green run to the Cape you've got a
Ryan finishing up its last little bit of
testing it moved from plum Brook earlier
this year our station up there in Ohio
down to KSC so we're looking at checking
it out throughout next year and
hopefully we'll have the first
integrated flight of SLS and Orion at
the end of 2021 and I'm telling you that
that is going to be a moment don't be a
thunderous boom right here at the
Kennedy Space Center so with Mars as the
end goal how does all of this get to
that end point
you bet no and I think that's what's so
important about the Artemis program
right our long-term vision is to get to
Mars but you know when you think about
Artemis everything that we're doing at
the moon is helping us learn prove out
capabilities and technologies work
through the right mission durations
understand how we utilize the resources
of the Moon potentially to go further
onto Mars so the technology the science
the exploration architecture that we're
putting together each and every piece of
it is helping us learn a little bit more
prove out a little bit more so we can
take that next giant leap to Mars and so
everything that we're doing at the moon
helps prepare us to move on to Mars how
about the activity in low-earth orbit
like Commercial Crew which is happening
today how does that help us for missions
to the moon yeah I think anytime you're
launching humans you're learning right
and you're taking what you've learned
and you're you're moving it forward to
the next to the next mission but I think
it's really about the business case if
you think about what Commercial Crew is
it's NASA moving from owning and
operating hardware to buying a service
right and if you remember just a few
weeks ago and
three contracts on the human landing
system two commercial companies and so
we're hoping that we moved to a day
we're actually buying a service to get
our astronauts back and forth to the
moon
so actually enabling the commercial
market to go from low-earth orbit all
the way out to lunar orbit and so
Commercial Crew is a great proving
ground for that helps us prove out that
business case build those partnerships
and then we get a feed forward to the
moon so it's a it means a lot this means
a lot as we move out it's really
exciting when you talk about the
Commercial Crew the commercial
commercial aspect going to the moon and
those partners um they're gonna be
studying those Landers to see if they
are viable for NASA
yeah working through a tremendous
process of with the commercial providers
and NASA engineers going through initial
designs right now looking at at the the
capabilities that they've proposed and
then trying to make decisions on which
which landing system goes early in 2024
which landing systems are better
prepared for sustainability out into the
later 20s and so that is going to be an
ongoing process throughout this year and
moving into next so it's gonna be really
exciting to kind of see what what comes
out is hey this is the lander that's
going to take the first woman and the
next man to the moon in 2024 right so
different than the time of Apollo we
went to the moon and that program
ultimately came to an end the idea here
though is to try to create some
sustainability and sustainability you
can get to sustainability if you have
reusability right and that's that's what
we're seeing with Commercial Crew for
sure but whenever you think about our
human landing system you're you're
looking at a system that we put out
there at the moon once we get to
sustainability and it's going back and
forth taking multiple trips to the lunar
surface back up to Gateway which you're
familiar with this kind of our smaller
space station we're going to put in
orbit around the moon so we're we are
building an architecture that is going
to enable reusability at the moon Apollo
never had that and so whenever you think
about driving down cost and increasing
access reusability sustainability are
critical so you get to see everything
from a very high level at NASA what's it
like for you personally I'm curious to
be here at the Kennedy Space Center to
watch a launch and just just see this
amazing facility where all of the
activity happens yeah I think sometimes
people think since I work at NASA I'm
around this stuff all the time I'm not
right I don't get to come down here
nearly as often as I'd like so it's just
as exciting for me as it is for anybody
else in this room
when you think about all the hard work
that our team has put in to get us to
this day to actually come down and be a
part of it with them I was just in it
just it's just overwhelming and
incredible so we're just a little bit
excited all right Gabe Sherman NASA's
chief of staff we appreciate you joining
us today and enjoy the launch I
certainly know you will if we're able to
get that one off we're gonna toss this
back now to Hawthorne California joining
us now is SpaceX is large black more to
discuss SpaceX's future ambitions to
visit the moon and mars thanks for
joining us again today for a second
round could you tell us just a little
bit about your background and what you
do here at space at SpaceX yeah well I'm
in charge of entry and landing for
starship which is SpaceX is next rocket
Falcon and before that I worked for many
years on the same thing for Falcon so
hopefully today you'll see another one
of those landings or adventure
awesome and speaking of that what role
does reusability play in getting people
to the Moon and Mars in the future well
it's really all about making human
spaceflight affordable and what you want
for that is a 100 percent of useable
rocket now Falcon is only partially
reusable the starship is going to be a
hundred percent reusable and we've
actually already started working with
NASA on using starship to send
astronauts to the surface of the Moon
for the first time since 1972
not only that starship will be refuel a
ball on orbit and the combination of
those two things will let us send people
basically anywhere in the solar system
with more payload for less money and I
think people have really been
contemplating it I think for the first
time we can seriously talk about things
like lunar bases or what SpaceX cares
about most a self-sustaining
civilization on Mars right so what
you're saying is I will have an
opportunity soon to get on board one of
those space
so speaking of reusability and landing I
know you mentioned starship will be
refuel in orbit but Falcon does come
back and land back on earth what what
are the challenges with landing actually
landing on the moon and landing on a
planet like Mars yeah well you you can't
land like a plane because the Moon and
Mars either have no atmosphere or have a
very thin atmosphere and even if you
could there's no runway that someone's
built for you so that's one of the
reasons that we do propulsive landing on
Falcon because we want to figure out how
to do propulsive landing about
fundamental architecture works on
basically any planet if you have no
atmosphere like the moon you do a
propulsive landing burn all the way if
you have a thick atmosphere like earth
you let the atmosphere slow you down as
you float down and do a short landing
boat at the end and for Mars which has
an atmosphere but a very thin one you do
something in between the two Wow yeah
that sounds really difficult and I'm
sure there's been a lot of effort put
into that can you tell us anything about
what we're working on now to get us to a
point where we can do a landing like
that in such a harsh environment yeah so
figuring out propulsive landing is
really the key part of it but what
people may not realize is that every
time we bring Falcon back we do
something called an entry burn so just
before we hit the atmosphere we like the
engines to slow the rocket down that
happens high up where the air is very
thin and it just so happens that the
conditions there are very similar to
what a Mars landing permit would look
like so even though it takes months to
get to Mars and you can only do it every
two years when the planets line up we
effectively get to practice Mars
propulsive landing every time we bring
Falcon back including hopefully today
Wow and as you mentioned every time
you've been Falcon back we learned
something new can you tell us a little
bit more about what we learn after the
the vehicles returned and we're able to
check out the vehicle yes so Jessica
actually mentioned this earlier that you
know I talked about how cost is really
one benefit of reusability that
reliability is the other benefit
I mean imagine that you do all this
planning to send a rocket up through the
rigors of launch and reentry
but you don't get to see the rocket
afterwards and what we would like to do
with reusability we've been able to do
with Falcon line is see the rocket
inspected and because of that we've been
able to correlate our models pre-flight
so what actually happens when you launch
re-enter and land a rocket right instead
of just guessing what happened to the
vehicle after it's left that that is
amazing well thank you again for joining
us today for a second round of flu the
weather works with us today in a couple
hours actually let's throw it back to
KSC with Murray
all right actually we have Lauren here
now today's mission opens up the door to
one day allowing the general public to
be able to visit places like the Moon
and Mars and as you've heard through
several interviews today reusability is
a really really important part of that
imagine if every time you flew a plane
from LA to New York you threw it away at
the end of the flight that would means
essentially airline travel would be too
expensive costing hundreds of millions
of dollars a flight and almost no one
would be able to fly and so that's what
SpaceX is trying to do here with reuse
allowing not just a handful of people to
be able to go to space but tens of
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
regular folks like you and me
to be able to to go to space so you know
myself you know when people like me have
a chance to go I know my dream is to
land on Jupiter's moon Europa
scientists believe that there is a
liquid water ocean underneath the ice
and that it has the potential to be
habitable and so I'm super excited to
get up close and personal to maybe some
space fish wheel and what about you
where would you go wow that's a pretty
interesting destination I think I would
like to go to Mars we've we've studied
Mars so much and looked at it and I
think maybe having a Martian base that
is dog friendly you know bring the pups
along because I think as we explore we
want to take our families or cultures
our traditions you know
with us and and you know flying with
Doug and Bob is cool but you know having
more people yeah
the puppers taking the coppers to space
I mean you know they already just needed
some maybe some like SpaceX type suits
for them but it's it's that's what it's
all about exploration like the settler
is going the West you know they took
everything with them and they started
these new communities in these new new
traditions and I think that's what we do
with space travel we start new
traditions and communities and bring
everyone together as one one family one
civilization absolutely we're here for
it and knowing that the opportunity to
fly to space is a private citizen is
really just right around the corner we
have a new poll question on Twitter for
you if given the opportunity to fly to
the moon now we're talking the moon
would you fly to the South Pole where no
one has ever been or would you go to the
Apollo 11 landing site so those are
going to be some interesting answers and
while there is not a ton of cargo on
today's mission dragon is carrying two
very special payloads
aside from Bob and Doug of course the
first of those payloads is a series of
custom art pieces entitled humankind by
Los Angeles artist Christian Tristan
Eden's these indestructible double-sided
paintings made from gold brass and
aluminum celebrate how far humanity has
come as well as how far we still have to
go it includes a beautiful homage to the
Saturn 5 rocket as well as a nod to Bob
and Doug's current ride to space and you
can find more images and information
about these pieces on SpaceX's social
channels next in the spirit of inspiring
the next generation of explorers we
wanted to celebrate the class of 2020
from kindergarten all the way to
graduate school so SpaceX and NASA
invited students from around the world
to submit their photo to fly on
America's first human spaceflight in
nearly a decade
each graduates photo was used to create
a mosaic image of our beautiful planet
Earth which we printed and it's now
being flown aboard Bob and Doug's flight
on the crew Dragon spacecraft we
received nearly 100,000 phone
that's a ton so thank you and
congratulations graduates yeah I've got
a couple family members and friends who
submitted their photos so they're
invited about see in their faces go to
space in that beautiful mosaic that was
really cool
and again that's what it's all about you
know everyone coming together with their
experiences and bringing them forward to
just space and I you know I think
regular people fly into space I mean
we're SpaceX is going to be flying you
know non government people non military
people but people that have a desire to
explore and do new things and traditions
off planet as we say sometimes yeah I
mean all this time since we've had the
International Space Station it's been
government astronauts performing the
research because you're the only ones
we've been able to send right but torus
though we've had people that paid their
way on a Soyuz rocket sure sure but it's
really the billionaire boys club you
know that's what Pharrell talks about
with you know it cost so much when in
the other space that I think that price
point will come down as we make this
more you know more amenable for everyday
people absolutely and eventually being
able to fly artists and musicians and
poets people can tell the story of what
they've seen out there in a way that
really connects to the soul of people
down on earth so they feel inspired to
go now following today's mission we will
be one step closer to a future where we
can all have that opportunity to gain
the orbital perspective and explore new
worlds in just over an hour from now Bob
and Doug will be the first people to
launch on an American vehicle in almost
a decade and for the SpaceX team if I
can try to speak for all of us which is
impossible but I will say it has been an
absolute honor to have the opportunity
today to have this stage to show the
world what we've poured our hearts into
over the years with our partners at NASA
and it's just deeply humbling to know
that the agency and that Bob and Doug
have entrusted us with this critical
mission the the responsibility that's on
our shoulders is is huge and we're just
so grateful to be here today absolutely
and I know that you know our NASA teams
really share in that sentiment we heard
we heard from just a handful of them
earlier when Bob and Doug were riding
out to the
pat but there are just there's so many
people that were you know we're probably
never gonna see or hear from on the
public stage but that have poured their
hearts and souls as you said into this
mission you know all the engineers up
late hours checking double check
checking triple checking everything to
troubleshoot and solve problems and get
us to this point so it's it's just
really awesome that we've made it to
this point when you think about legacy
Katherine Johnson who helped get John
Glenn to space her daughters are
watching right now and that again that
legacy going forward to the future of
space travel yeah it's powerful Wow and
we heard from two icons of science and
exploration on Wednesday and we couldn't
resist sharing these shoutouts with you
one more time Wow we're making history
again the NASA program I'm there with
you guys in spirit Bob good luck I know
you'll be fine I'll be watching and they
got everything crossed arms legs
I'm tighten or not can't wait for you to
get back safely
[Music]
this is the first time a u.s. built
rocket has taken people into space in
nine years it's quite an accomplishment
so for us at the Planetary Society more
rockets means more exploration more
people in space means more exploration
more countries involved in the endeavor
of space flight means more exploration
this is how we know the cosmos and our
place within it
so congratulations SpaceX here's wishing
your team and the crew especially a safe
journey and the joy of discovery let's
go so great to hear from William Shatner
and Bill Nye two very recognizable faces
following along on the mission and and
we want to go over to Dan and Jesse and
Hawthorne where we are now just one hour
and 18 minutes from launch dan Jesse hey
thanks for yeah one hour 18 minutes I
think we're tying ourselves and knots
just like Captain Kirk where we're
really hoping the weather cooperates in
about 20 minutes or so we might clear so
we're getting hopeful we're gonna our
hopes up yes yes very excited again
we're t-minus one hour and 18 minutes
from launch and we are the anticipation
is real over here since arriving at the
spacecraft Bob and Doug were helped by
our closeout engineers to get into their
seats attach their suits to special
umbilicals that provide breathing air
pressurized nitrox and communications
linked to dragons systems they conducted
leak checks which were successful and
communications checks with the core here
in Hawthorne which is the person who
will speak to them directly throughout
the mission as well as the launch
director in Florida this is where they
are checking their comm pass through
both ground stations and the tracking
and data relay satellites that we'll use
to talk to the crew the entire way to
the station and after all of those suit
leak checks were successful the closeout
team was able to get out of the Dragon
capsule and seal up that hatch which
also got its own leak check and was
confirmed successful at this point the
closeout team is out of the path or away
from the BDA the blast danger area and
weather operators are about to kick off
their final checks on wind speeds at the
pad which
be used during the final go/no-go for
launch so we're all keeping eyes on the
weather right now before we get to that
final go no-go all the various teams
both NASA and SpaceX are gonna do
internal go polls just making sure
conditions are right with Falcon 9 the
dragon the crew the range and the space
station before the final go is given so
let's check back in with the man over in
Houston Gary for a status and the team
supporting the space station for their
readiness for launch thanks Dan the team
here in Mission Control Houston remains
go for launch we're also very hopeful
about that weather all systems onboard
the station that are required to be
healthy for this mission
are continuing to look good Chris
Cassidy is we're wrapping up his workday
and we'll be watching Bob and Doug
launch here in just under an hour
so station power and communication
systems are normal computers and
networks used for monitoring dragons
approach have been checked out and the
cabins and the station cabins atmosphere
and pressure are as expected and ready
to welcome two new crew members aboard
Mission Control will be closely
monitoring Bob and Doug's flight and
checking off milestones for most of the
flight and this very same team will be
coming back tomorrow to be ready when
dragon gets in range of the
international space station and we begin
integrated operations and prepare for
Dragon stocking so I'll send it back
International Space Station team here is
ready for launch
go Falcon 9 go dragon and Godspeed to
Bob and Doug all right thanks Gary if
you are just now joining us you picked a
really good time we're just a little
over an hour to launch and welcome to
our coverage for the mission known as
demonstration mission 2 or demo 2
liftoff time still holding for 322 p.m.
Eastern
tracking no issues with Falcon 9 or
dragon everything good with the range so
far we're just really keeping an eye on
that weather over the last three hours
our crew members Doug Hurley and Bob
bankin down there spacex suits in the
historic crew quarters suit up room
after that they walked out of crew
quarters just as every astronaut to fly
from space from this port has done since
Apollo 7
and then they were transported over to
the pad where the crew members entered
the SpaceX crew Dragon spacecraft that
we're looking in live today is a
historic launch it will be the first
time a commercially built spacecraft
will launch people into orbit and the
first time the US has sent people to the
space station from American soil
since 2011 with the retirement of the
space shuttle program over the next hour
we will conduct a series of polls to get
ready for launch have Bob and Doug arm
the launch escape system and begin
fueling Falcon 9 launch is set for 322
p.m. Eastern this will include a
12-minute flight to orbit and then a
19-hour flight to dock with the
International Space Station tomorrow
morning today's mission is the
culmination of years of work between
teams at SpaceX and NASA demo2 is gonna
be an end-to-end flight test starting
with this launch today going on to dock
with the space station tomorrow and then
splashing down at the end of their
mission this is going to be the final
test for NASA to certify SpaceX for
regular crew flights to the space
station we've been hearing a little bit
from the crew onboard dragon which you
can see on your right screen they are
currently strapped into their seats and
already through communications and leak
checks they're able to follow all the
milestones still ahead on those display
panels just above them getting insight
into all Dragon and Falcon 9 systems as
we proceed towards launch so at t-minus
one hour in 13 minutes let's check in
with John I for a status update on the
vehicles what's the update John thank
Jesse well not much it not much to add
to what Dan and Jesse just brought up we
have a smooth countdown this afternoon
SpaceX team is working no issues as the
pace begins to pick up here in the last
70 minutes on Falcon 9 we did get the
team on console earlier you heard the
contracts between the responsible
engineers and the crew the engineers
will be making calls on a set for the
crews benefit so they want to make sure
that they could hear and before we go
the propulsion checkouts of the first
and second stages are beginning right
now we're watching them begin to go
through the process opening valves that
check will go for about another ten
minutes and that'll be our last one
until propellant loading now the team
will assess readiness for launch with a
final go no-go poll at t-minus 45
minutes and that will be followed by
propellant loading starting at t-minus
35 minutes now earlier today dragon
operators also performed a series of
checkouts of dragons flight systems the
spacecraft is also currently go for
launch our NASA Crew astronauts Doug
Hurley and Bob Behnken are currently
inside dragon the hatch is closed
the SpaceX ground crew has left the
tower the next major event for Dragon is
retracted the crew access arm that you
can see currently alongside the capsule
that will happen somewhere between
t-minus 45 and t-minus 42 minutes now
the range is currently clear for launch
from historic pad 39a the worldwide
network of ground stations and the
tracking and data relay satellites are
ready to support dragon as it heads into
orbit the weather that's the one concern
we will get a weather brief at t-minus
one hour so just under 12 minutes from
now
currently the ground and upper altitude
winds are go so that's one thing that we
can check is green at the current time
we did have some rain earlier that
appears to have led up but we are red on
conditions for both the electric field
at surface levels lightning and cumulus
clouds there is a expectation at a
forecast that will be coming up at about
t-minus one hour also may give us
clearance of those conditions so
everything is focusing now on the
weather brief at t-minus 1 hours also we
should hope to hear about the final
check on the asset corridor that's the
weather along the Atlantic seaboard in
case dragon had to abort on the way to
space the conditions there have been
marginal but the expectation that it
would be good for launch
but we will get all of that coming up
here very shortly prior to entering
propellant load
now today we are aiming for a launch at
3:20 2:45 p.m. Eastern Daylight Saving
Time or 19 hours 22 minutes 45 seconds
Universal Time once we begin loading for
pellet there's no opportunity to change
t0
so once propel is loading we're
committed and we'll get one chance at it
today but currently at t-minus one hour
ten minutes and thirty seconds
everything except the weather is go for
launch
thanks John for that detailed update
we've got an extensive history now of
flying Falcon 9 from the Florida coast
and just last year completed a test run
of a mission worth less than an hour
from beginning here today the purpose of
that mission was to demonstrate dragons
capability to safely and reliably fly to
and from the International Space Station
the success of demo1 was a really
exciting moment to where we are today
and right now we're getting ready to fly
US astronauts from US soil for the first
time since 2011 dragon and Falcon 9
together have years of operational
experience or what we refer to as flight
heritage as I mentioned earlier SpaceX
has successfully completed 21 flights of
Dragon to and from orbit since 2010
including 20 trips to the International
Space Station not only have we conducted
thousands of hours of testing we've also
enhanced and added a number of safety
features to Dragon much of what was
learned with the cargo dragon was
leveraged in the design of this new
vehicle it's fully autonomous which
means it can basically fly itself but
also features that full manual override
capability just in case of emergency
many of the other enhancements helped
towards SpaceX's goal of reusability and
less refurbishment time between missions
so let's take a closer look at these
advancements standing at almost 27 feet
tall from the very bottom of the trunk
to the very top of the nosecone crew
dragons comprised of two main elements
you have the capsule which is designed
to hold crew and pressurize cargo and
then you have the trunk which holds
unpressurized cargo as well as having a
solar array and radiator and the No
koan at the top of the capsule protects
the docking system as well as the get
guidance navigation control system or
what we call GNC the nosecone opens for
docking and remains attached to the crew
Dragon spacecraft and that's unlike the
previous version of Dragon and that
helps towards our reusability efforts
Julie ops at the nose cone is that trunk
it has attachment points for Falcon 9
the Dragon capsule and it can hold cargo
on the very outside of the trunk one
half of it of it contains a radiator
that rejects heat from the active
thermal control system into space that's
the white part and that uses SpaceX's
new pekin silane technology the other
half contains the solar cells used to
charge the spacecraft batteries and
though we only have two astronauts on
board today the spacecraft is actually
designed to accommodate up to seven crew
members with modular seats that can be
removed and replaced by additional cargo
the seats are made of carbon fiber and
our custom size for any crew member
flying onboard the control panel
centered right between the pilot and the
commander seats and has those three
touchscreen displays that gives the crew
insight into Dragon and even the ability
to operate the vehicle and fly it
manually and finally our super Draco
launch escape system is a key safety
feature of crew dragon giving the crew
the ability to safely escape from the
time of launch all the way to orbit as
we look to the future beyond this test
flight later this year the first
operational crewed mission for NASA will
take place NASA astronauts Mike Hawk
doesn't try to review your launch commit
criteria and indicate readiness at the
appropriate time step 54 69 load launch
that's a good sign that was the launch
director we're getting ready to pull the
teams as we move towards that go no-go
for propellant loading which happens at
about 45 minutes before launch but back
to our crew one mission NASA astronauts
Mike Hopkins Victor Glover and Shanna
Walker and sweetie Noguchi of the japan
aerospace exploration agency or JAXA
were chosen to support this mission but
today Doug Hurley is the spacecraft
commander for this mission
he previously flew on
Space Shuttle missions as the pilot on
sts-127 and sts-135 which was the final
space shuttle flight here's a closer
look at Doug Hurley very excited yeah
very excitable oh yeah I think we're
ready I think we're certainly ready
joining the SpaceX demo to test he is a
Marine Corps colonel and test pilot he
was selected as an astronaut in 2000 he
piloted space shuttle endeavour and
Atlantis for sts-135 the final space
shuttle mission introducing NASA
astronauts Doug Hurley it's a
life-changing process in so many ways to
fly into space it's just overwhelming in
some some respects
just the sensations the rumbling the
shaking the acceleration my name is Doug
Hurley and I'm the spacecraft commander
for the demo2 mission to the
International Space Station this will be
the first time the dragon that crew on
board and so there's a myriad of
objectives we want to achieve for this
mission what would work on orbit what
might not work on orbit
what would definitely work to be able to
just have the entire integrated team
that's going to support us getting to
and from Space Station it was really
neat being part of it you know we are
the lucky ones that get to fly it
but we certainly not for one second take
for granted the amount of effort that so
many other people had to put into this
to make it successful for Doug
personally he's worked so hard through
his entire life to get to where we are
right now as a test pilot this would be
the dream to fly any vehicle so it makes
me so happy to see that he is to be part
of this mission the spacecraft commander
I'm just glad to see his hard work and
his dream has come true for that it's
been a long road in a lot of ways for
not only us but certainly for all the
folks that work in the Commercial Crew
program as well as SpaceX in our case
just working to get to this point
[Music]
and we're a little over one hour three
and a half minutes away from launch now
let's learn a little bit more about the
man sitting next to Doug Hurley inside
dragon NASA astronaut Bob bankin my
career at NASA is a kind of spanned a
couple of decades at this point I
arrived with the class of 2000 went
through the training program primarily
focused on the Space Shuttle in the
International Space Station learning
those systems having launched a couple
times on vehicles you know the the
second time was definitely different
than the first time you can feel a
little bit guilty hey should I study one
more thing or one more piece of
information I should get am i really
prepared or not so that's definitely
different between where I was on my
first flight and where I'm at right now
for me personally as a spouse watching
everything that bob has put into this
over the last five years the dedication
that he's shown the perseverance is
pretty special for both of us though the
way our minds work it won't be until
sort of the mission is complete that you
have really a chance to savor it and
celebrate it this is a huge
accomplishment for an Air Force flight
test engineer to be part of the
demonstration mission of a brand new
vehicle it's going to be amazing without
a partner that has that same
appreciation I think it can be
challenging for some folks there's a
there's a lot of work and a lot of time
that takes away from family that you
know that my spouse appreciates and I
love her for that on a deeply personal
level I'm really excited that my son is
get to get a chance to see me I launched
into space being an astronaut has been a
little bit of an abstraction thing for
him because he's seen me do it in old
videos but he hasn't seen me do it for
real and so I'm excited for him to see
this launch really my role on the demo2
mission is to make sure that we get this
vehicle tested and evaluated so that we
can move on to more operational missions
at the International Space Station
we've got a lot of objectives onboard
the vehicle that we need to accomplish
to really make sure that it's good to go
well make sure all those systems are
working during the test flight so that
the future missions will have them
available even if they don't plan to
utilize them through years of the the
NASA team I'm helping to share that
experience and teaching them the lessons
that we've learned by going through this
now there's another capability in the
u.s. besides NASA to operate something
of this magnitude I want to thank the
entire Commercial Crew program team
that's worked together to get to this
point where we've got vehicles in the
launch pad ready to head to the
International Space Station if we look
even further into the not so distant
future flying on a mission to space will
be an option for more people as SpaceX
plans to also fly private astronauts
onboard dragon earlier this year SpaceX
signed an agreement with these space
tourism companies space adventures to
fly up to four passengers on an orbital
trip aboard dragon as early as next year
and of course it's NASA that is making
private astronaut missions to the space
station of possibility we are looking
forward to these missions and we hope
that you guys are all - all right we are
just 20 seconds away from t-minus one
hour this is going to be a really big
moment that everyone's gonna want to
listen to we're expecting a weather
update obviously hoping that the weather
is improving and so we should find out
in the next 10 seconds or so so we're
gonna stand by for a moment and wait for
the Corps to give Bob and Doug a call
and then we'll all hear SpaceX we're at
t-minus one hour you are go for Section
six when ready report go for lunch go
put it work
and that right there was a call for the
crew to refer to some of their
procedures they do some final checks you
can see them checking harnesses checking
helmets just making sure that they're
strapped in and ready to go and once
they're done with that crew will report
their readiness for launch
spacex dragon and decimal for Bob and
Ira go for launch
copy go for launch and next up will be
gonna go 40-45 camera alright the crew
is go for launch so we are inside of one
hour still waiting for the weather
update but I mean this day this day is
one for the history books we're
returning crewed launches to station
from American soil on American Rockets
it's been almost nine long years since
we retired the space shuttle program I
remember that day I'm gonna remember
this day it's been a long road to get
here countless hours by thousands of
dedicated professionals from NASA and
SpaceX it's been an exciting week but
this last final hour is just so exciting
right now
today's mission will be crew Dragons
second test flight and its first test
with humans on board it's been an
awesome countdown so far whether we're
still waiting for that update so it's
still a watch item but the crew is go
for launch so at t-minus 45 minutes
hopefully we'll get an update on that
weather we've had a really clean
countdown so far it started with suit up
just over three hours ago the SpaceX
team helping Bob and Doug put on their
suits conducting the initial checkouts
including an initial pressure and leak
check before they got to the actual
walkout and all of that done and that
operations and check-out facility the
crew walkout was where Bob and Doug gave
their final goodbyes to friends and
family gathered outside the operations
and check-out building before they began
that roughly twenty minute ride to pad
39a really touching moment saying
goodbye to their family both their wives
and sons right in front of them a very
touching moment incredible to be able to
watch these moments
and as they got into their Tesla's we
got to watch them ride all the way to
the pad and we got some great footage
there and as you can see on your screen
this is some playback from earlier of
them getting into those Tesla's about to
make that drive down to the pad once
they got to the pad they did take a
minute to take in the sights and they
headed up the fixed service structure to
begin the process called true ingress
where Bob and Doug entered the and there
you can see on your screen as they're
coming through the crew access arm
entering the white room right before
they are able to ingress into the
vehicle there again this is from earlier
this off earlier and as we said that
white room the last place on planet
Earth they're standing before they climb
into dragon for the ride uphill SpaceX
carrying over a tradition that NASA had
had where that was traditionally the
room from Gemini Apollo and the space
shuttle that last place about 30 minutes
ago we're back with some live video here
the team was able to close dragon's
hatch with Bob and Doug safe inside so
we are under an hour ago things are
gonna pick up as we get close to that go
no-go to begin propellant loading and
then arming the launch escape system the
crew pole for readiness was completed at
t-minus 60 minutes and the dragon pull
for prop load is coming up here in just
about 30 seconds at t minus 55 minutes
and then following that will be t-minus
45 minutes will be the internal Mission
Control Hawthorne pull and then they
launch director's pull for propellant
loading when we get to about t-minus 40
minutes the crew access arm will retract
and Bob and Doug will get the call to
close their visors and arm the launch
escape system this is the automated
system in place that can fire the eight
super Draco thrusters on dragon to
quickly separate the crew from the
rocket either on the pad or during the
flight on the ride uphill and once we
reach t-minus 35 minutes for
loading for the Falcon nine will begin
we got there on Wednesday we got all the
way down to about 17 minutes before
launch before we had to cancel because
of weather but we're still we're
optimistic right now conditions have
been improving and so we're looking to
press ahead once again into loading fuel
onto that Falcon 9 rocket throughout the
countdown we've been getting some
incredible views of the astronauts
inside dragon just making all of their
final preparations some close-up views
of their suits and on the displays as
they just are strapped in and ready for
launch
the team's often describe the suits as
an extension of that Dragon spacecraft
you can always think of it as a mini
spacecraft inside of a spacecraft all of
the life support everything that they
need just like the caddy and konban WA
technical pole is complete no
constraints to proceed into launch
escape system arming and propellant load
and there's that call out that the crew
is ready they are ready to load prop
onto dragon so we are pushing forward
towards t0 and while those suits do look
rate they are also engineered to correct
or connect directly into dragon seats to
provide communications cooling and the
ability to pressurize it's necessary all
right well we did get the call out that
the technical teams in the ground are
ready for launch escape arming and
propellant loading again things starting
to pick up things really starting to
feel real let's jump down real quick to
the team at Kennedy see if you guys are
just as excited I can't sit still right
now yeah it's it's hard to sit still in
here right lane still I know I know it's
it's so awesome when we see them sitting
there in their suits were less than an
hour away now so far things look like we
might make it we might make it so I want
to ask you what it was like the first
time you put on a space suit when you
knew you were going to space oh that was
February of 2008 we're in the ONC
building getting the pumpkin suits on
but different than the SpaceX fly SpaceX
is but it was it was kind of surreal you
know and to think that all these it took
ten years of training to fly in space it
took me ten years from when I got in the
Corps 1998 to fly in February of 2008 so
it was a long road to get there but it
was so worth it and so sweet and you
know learning how to use the green apple
the connections for oxygen for cooling
much different than these suits that we
have over SpaceX and so it's a lot more
complicated to to go through that whole
series of things that you have to do to
make sure you're safe in the suit but
we've evolved we're ready and they look
so cool and calm and collected in their
their suits and in the vehicle they're
focusing and getting ready to find space
and there's so much excitement around
the center I know Leland you've been
getting some messages you got another
message from another astronaut yeah
sunny Williams
okay so sunny she was one of the
original four who trained with Bob and
Doug from the beginning of the
Commercial Crew program and she's one of
my classmates look at her there what is
she wearing today I'm asking where the
warm ball yeah yes you can she can mix
it up but yeah Sunny's awesome she's
training to fly on the Boeing star liner
on in the not-too-distant future so
really glad she's watching and showing
some love so thanks a lot sunny for
sending that note and again we're
looking at a live view of the crew
dragon on top of a falcon 9 rocket you
can see the crew access arm to the right
of your screen that's the hallway that
Bob and Doug walked down to get into the
white room which was the last place we
saw them standing up before they climbed
inside dragon and again that wider shot
their launch complex 39a where we are
inside of an hour from liftoff and I
think we're just a couple minutes away
from the pole we're gonna hear before
they start propellant load again a
two-stage rocket there and gosh you guys
the weather looks it looks not that bad
I mean obviously that is not an official
forecast
but it doesn't look quite as bad as it
did Wednesday we've got a little bit
better odds so there's the countdown
clock where we're going to pause to
listen to that calm
if you're just joining us we're less
than 50 minutes from the scheduled
liftoff of the Falcon 9 rocket carrying
crew dragon and if we start to hear any
kind of update on whether or Polling we
will pause to listen in for that but if
things go as scheduled we should be
hearing the launch director verify go
for propellant load at about t minus t
minus 45 minutes so we're gonna send it
over to Hawthorne to carry the ball John
instructor or Jesse are you there that's
whether it's go at this time
dragon copy got weather and there you
heard that call out so far we have good
weather we are go for launch today this
was getting really exciting I don't know
about you Dan my heart is beating pretty
fast right now for those words since
Wednesday oh yeah
we did we did hear a call to the crew
just in case you missed it that they
were only tracking one final weather
constraint it was the cumulus cloud rule
they were expecting it to clear up
within 10 minutes and it's cleared up
now so we are currently go on weather
yes and it's been pretty incredible to
be so close to launch and the road
leading up to this point has been pretty
incredible as well it has been it's been
a partnership between NASA and SpaceX
we've been working together since we
since SpaceX started flying cargo to the
International Space Station now getting
ready to launch crew and we've been
really fortunate to work with not only a
lot of international partners on the
international space station but a lot of
every writer here the control room will
be closing doors here once we start with
propellant load any last-minute
BioBricks please go ahead couple of
those in the next few minutes and the
launch launch director just getting the
teams ready will be coming up on that
propellant loading again that starts at
about thirty five minutes prior to
liftoff so in about 12 minutes from now
there's gonna be a go no-go coming up
really soon so let's go over to our man
John I for the latest John
Steve - 47 minutes 24 seconds we're
continuing countdown as you just heard
the launch director and launch team are
preparing for the readiness for launch
Paul now the launch director is
currently checking the dragon mission
director NASA launch manager for their
readiness and actually it sounds like
everybody is good there the launch
director will then ask the team he'll
tell them the pole is open and the 13
members of the SpaceX launch team will
be electrically pulled for their go to
load propellant as well as continue all
the way to launch now we will hear that
poll results and a briefing from the
launch director at about t-minus 45
minutes the good news right now is that
the weather is go all the conditions
that were read shortly a while ago at
t-minus one hour have cleared where is
the weather forecaster said cautiously
optomistic cut down the from those
complete weirdo for propellant load now
we got an early call out this ultra
chokes here to retract the access arm on
time however that harming access arm
retract at t-minus 45 minutes got an
early call from SpaceX launch director
Mike Taylor that the pole is go you also
heard the direction t-minus 45 minutes
to prepare for retract of the crew arm
as we hear more discussion we'll stop
and let you listen in but right now
weather for liftoff ground level winds
are good 10 to 15 miles an hour well
within limit upper altitude balloons
show that conditions are acceptable the
red weather conditions have cleared up
the last one being cumulus clouds and
the probability of violation is set at
30 percent right now so that's 70
percent chance of good weather we're
continuing to watch there is about a
less than 10 percent chance of lightning
we're also watching the abort corridor
off of the Atlantic coast in case for
example at stage separation dragon had
to abort into the ocean the conditions
there are acceptable there has not been
light
lately the weather winds are good
light rain it is go but NASA is going to
continue to watch those conditions
t-minus 45 minutes and Counting reminder
on hold and launch escape protocol for
non urgent no-go conditions recess ee or
LD they will approve aborting launch out
of sequence and proceed to launch abort
for urgent issues affecting the safety
of the operation operator shall call
hold hold hold on the countdown net
launch control immediately abort the
launch on a sequence and proceed to the
launch abort auto sequence operators
also advise launch director weather
structural breaker fire is imminent or
occurring her dragon manual escape
flight rules reminder on fire alarm
instructions in the event of a fire
alarm key operators previously briefed
will remain as their post while the
alarm is evaluated the event that
personal safety is threatened evacuate
to the south facing emergency exit which
leads directly outside at this time
weather is go for launch you can see on
the screen we're inside t-minus 40 we're
t-minus 40 four minutes five seconds
crew access every okay SpaceX launch
director is given the final brief to the
crew and we will beginning a little
propellant loading at t-minus 35 minutes
so right now at Falcon 9 ready to get
into propellant loading dragon crew
getting configured set up the arm is
pulling away the range is go for launch
they continue to monitor the air in the
C space everything looks good and we
finally have gotten green across the
board on the weather conditions but we
can't take a deep breath quite yet we're
gonna have to watch the weather all the
way down to t0 of here at Kennedy Space
Center and out in the Atlantic in the
abort zones now earlier we saw many of
you following the launch from the United
States on our hotspot map now that we're
inside now where we're seeing large
numbers of folks logging on tuning in
from coast to coast and around the world
so we'd like to know is this your first
time watching a launch live not counting
Wednesday and if not how many
you seen before tell us using the
hashtag launch America from your
favorite social media platform and with
that at t-minus 42 minutes 50 seconds
conditions are go and we are toning down
for an on-time launch let's send it
better as the action begins to pick up
on the pad dragon SpaceX your go for
Section seven clothes visors and arm
launch escape system we will but section
seven and work sizes come in close all
right the countdown clock is continuing
to take my heart is continuing to beat
five million beats a second and we are
getting so so close right dragon in
seven point two visors are close we're
arming launch escape system has just
heard the crew is arming the launch
escape system that is one of the
absolute last big milestones prior to
liftoff other than nominal Falcon
operations so just a minute ago we saw
the crew access arm retract and
obviously we just heard on the comms Bob
and Doug
getting ready to arm the launch escape
system and so that is something that
protects them all the way to orbit so
when when fueling starts at about
t-minus 35 minutes so just over six
minutes from now they will have the
capability to abort to separate from
Falcon 9 either on the pad or even after
liftoff that's a critical safety
capability and we are going to go over
to Hawthorn now to take us through these
next minutes Jesse we did hear that call
out that they are arming the launch
escape systems are very exciting SpaceX
has designed a crew dragon and Falcon 9
to be the safest launches launch system
ever flown so we brought back NIC Picone
SpaceX has nicked the cone
more about this again thanks for coming
back and joining us today Nick hey Jesse
happy to be here this is the monitoring
launch here with our recovery and ground
operations tips awesome and Nicky was
our mission manager for our inflatable
tests earlier this year and now works on
the StarLink team Nick on Wednesday you
talked about the launch escape system
could you just give us a brief summary
today for those that are joining today
sure so the launch escape system again
is our ultimate safety feature to keep
Bob and Doug safe in the event of a
major falcon anomaly on the pad the
system is designed to automatically fire
if either vehicle detects a dangerous
condition developing if that happens
dragon will use its eight super Draco
engines to push the capsule off and away
to a safe distance away from this Falcon
miss this capability is absolutely
critical
it's what keeps the crew safe and we're
now acting on the pad with it protecting
the crew and as you mentioned the launch
escape system allows the dragon to
separate and get away from the vehicle I
believe it goes into the ocean what what
happens after it lands safely in the
ocean correct so for most of our failure
modes the
you
if something happens so the nominal
stuff is all kind of automated but if
something happens where they have to
intervene with those touchscreens that's
what they're thinking and we are we're
just inside 23 minutes now so on
Wednesday we were five minutes further
in the countdown when we heard that call
to scrub and we the weather was still
very touch-and-go at this point on
Wednesday but today it at least for
right now I don't want to jinx better
today yeah and it feels like I'm feeling
it a lot more than I did and you know
speaking of Bob and Doug and them being
really calm and cool and collected
hasn't had the opportunity to be in
meetings with them and to watch them
train I have to say and to all of my
friends who work with them every single
day
the feedback is always just what great
people they are right and just how not
just bright and sharp they are but just
good people and around the office we
often refer to them as the dads the
dad's they're dad's they are dead and
we've met their families and when you
sweetie you see people in that very
personal level it starts to mean so much
there they are
a part of our team you know they're and
they're not a customer they're our team
they're not a payload they're our team
they're our family and so we're just so
excited to see the dads up there today
all right we're gonna go send it over to
Gary for an update from Houston Gary hey
Murray the Space Station team here is
focused all eyes are on the system
checks that are happening across the
board and we're listening in as we close
in on launch and I can tell you that
things are looking very good Chris
Cassidy will be watching from the
International Space Station right now
flying over the Pacific Ocean it's
heading to cross right over the launch
pad we might even get some good views
from the station hope to be capturing
those we'll have the launch view in the
big screen up front and everyone's
excited to see our two members on their
way to the International Space Station
but before we get to it I just want to
pass on good luck from the entire flight
operations community here in Houston
it's always exciting to be doing
something wholly new and history-making
with stage
operations and we can't wait to see our
team members Bob and Doug in low Earth
orbit and heading to the International
Space Station that's it from us here in
Mission Control Houston
I'll send it back over to the team at
Hawthorne for the latest happening there
John t-minus 20 minutes 30 seconds with
down everything is still looking good
for launch of Falcon 9 and dragon 22
minutes 45 seconds after the hour you
can see a large white cloud coming off
of the strong back that is normal as we
get ready to load the second stage with
liquid oxygen we have to chill in the
plumbing lines going up that strong back
and so as we relieve pressure the moist
humid Florida air condenses around it
and that gives you the cloud so that
tells us that things are actually on
schedule we did begin propellant load at
t-minus 35 minutes fuel loading on the
second stage I believe we just heard the
call up that it is complete first stage
feel load is continuing and right now
that's a little more than it's about 60%
of the way full so things are looking
good second stage is getting ready to
begin the liquid oxygen loading after
they finished chilling in the lines that
you see on the monitor they'll begin to
load at t-minus 16 minutes and 30
seconds the range right now is go ready
to support weather continues to be go
now as we inch our way closer we're
keeping our fingers crossed we're
waiting to hear if anybody calls out an
issue but for the moment as you can see
on the screen it looks good now on the
dragon thar I'd the dragon mission
director and the team there are
reporting no issues they've done their
communications checkouts the crew access
arm as you can see is retracted away
from the spacecraft the crew is strapped
in and they are ready to go now final
instructions will be going to the crew
at t-minus 10 minutes the crew displays
will be configured for launch and that
setup will give astronauts Bob Behnken
and Doug Hurley insight into how the
launch is proceeding and provides
constant updates on vehicle health we've
already heard the crew give their go
close their visors and get ready for
launch for Dragon it'll enter terminal
count at t-minus five minutes when it
transitions the internal power will hear
continued call-outs on the countdown net
as we get close to zero and to liftoff
but right now at t-minus 18 minutes 15
seconds everything continues to be go
for an on-time launch so Dan Jessie
things looking pretty good how are they
doing over at your stand
things are great from about 15 feet away
from you John I and honestly things are
looking pretty great down at the pad
there we're seeing a lot more blue in
the sky Green is the color we want when
we're talking about weather and that's
wherever sitting right now so we're
continuing to countdown we are under 18
minutes away from liftoff again it's an
instantaneous liftoff at it's going to
be 12 22 and 45 seconds here on the west
coast 322 and 45 seconds over on the
East Coast there in Florida just a
reminder it's going to be about a 90
minute ride up to orbit for the Falcon 9
and Bob and Doug on board dragon
it'll be a two-stage flight so we'll see
you the first age fly until we hear miko
or main engine cutoff about two and a
half minutes into flight after that the
second stage will take over and continue
to power them the rest of the way
second engine cutoff comes in just under
nine minutes at about 8 minutes and 44
seconds following that second stage
completing its job it'll continue to
Coast for about three minutes they'll do
a slight attitude adjustment and no out
any rate so make sure it's not in any
kind of a spin before they do separation
so that's when the Dragon spacecraft
will physically separate from the Falcon
nine vehicle and Bob and Doug will be
flying free it's about a 19 hour ride if
we launch today on time so that means
Bob and Doug will get on orbit they'll
have a number of burns or those firings
of those Draco thrusters that they'll do
will be to lock load started we hear the
LOX the liquid oxygen load has now
started on stage two again they're going
to be doing a series of burns
the way uphill towards the International
Space Station v spread out over the the
first 16 hours or so of their flight
until they get much closer and it's time
for that approach in docking and we are
expecting that with an on-time launch to
happen today that will be coming
tomorrow in the afternoon all right now
that we're under 16 minutes away we have
a special guest joining us I'm gonna
toss it over to Jessie we are t-minus 15
minutes and 45 seconds from liftoff of
our second demonstration mission today
and we have the honor of having
he longs for hiring me we thank you one
for hiring you as well thank you so much
for joining us we'll let you get back to
Mission Control and good luck with
launch today thanks Jesse and Godspeed
Bob and Doug well we are so excited we
are just a few minutes away from
countdown so we are going to turn it
over to Dan and John for the final
minutes in terminal count
take it away John II - 13 minutes 30
seconds continuing to countdown we're
continuing to load Phil on to the first
stage that should finish up in just
about 6 minutes Phil is completely
loaded on the second stage that's closed
out and we are continuing to load liquid
oxygen on both the first and second
stage the liquid oxygen load beginning
on the second stage just about three and
a half minutes ago we are also loading
courage and a kalium into the storage
vessels on the first and second stage
giving in the last little bits of helium
when we keep it cryogenic cold and
liquefied that gets us just like we do
with liquid oxygen the maximum amount
into the storage volume so that we can
get the most performance out of the
vehicle right now we are in a fairly
quiet state on the vehicle ground pump
continuing to put the propellant in to
first and second stages next significant
issue call-outs that we're gonna hear
probably be inside the t-minus 10
minutes when they talk to the crew will
listen for that but at the moment
everything continuing to look good at
t-minus 12 minutes and 20 seconds
getting real close now John it's only a
little over 12 minutes away
just a reminder for everybody it's about
a nine minute ride uphill we'll have
some dueling boxes going on as that
first stage is going to be coming home
while the second stage is carrying Bob
and Doug into orbit obviously we'll be
keeping an eye on our astronauts the
whole way uphill some of the calls that
you'll be hearing is there will be what
we call performance calls over the
dragon to ground the entire way uphill
and you'll just hear some of the SpaceX
engineers calling out trajectories and
booster performance so we're always
looking for that word nominal I know
that's one of John's favorite words
that's one of mine too
we want to hear novel as much as
possible up on the way uphill you might
also hear some number and letter
combinations and those correspond to the
different abort zones that father
daughter in during their flight uphill
there's 1a and 1b which signify that
they're on the first stage those carry
them from there in the cape all the way
up to about the very top of North
Carolina and then we'll have 2a through
2e or two echo and that will be on the
second stage and that goes from North
Carolina all the way up to about the tip
of Newfoundland so in the northern
Atlantic and then there is a zone of the
northern Atlantic that we're going to
avoid and so you should hear the
call-out be something similar to forward
to Shannon and that just refers to
Shannon Ireland which they'll be going
off the coast of Ireland at the later
stages of the second stage if they have
to abort
so just prepping you now for some of
those calls you're hopefully going to
hear that word nominal a whole lot on
the way uphill ten and a half minutes
things are pretty quiet as John I said
it'll pick up it right at about ten
minutes we'll wait for the crew just to
confirm that their displays are in order
the crew is already strapped in and
reported that they are go for launch
and we'll continue to watch the fuel
gauges tick up on the Falcon 9 vehicle
until fueling cuts off at just about two
minutes prior to launch
dragon SpaceX confirmed displays are a
quick figure for lunch wagon displays
are configured for launch
copy Bob Doug on behalf of the entire
SpaceX team it's been a huge honor to
help you get ready for today's historic
mission know that we're with you have an
amazing flight and enjoy those views of
our beautiful planet
thanks Jay it is absolutely our honor to
be part of this huge effort to did the
United States back in the launch
business we'll talk to you for more -
thank you thanks for those words
the SpaceX Corps so again that voice
that's gonna be talking to Bob and Doug
throughout their mission from right here
in Hawthorne just offering a few quick
words the crew did confirm their crew
displays are configured for launch we
are coming up on 9 minutes and Counting
we've gotten through t-minus 10 minute
with the career discussions activity is
now gonna switch over to Falcon 9 our
next major event comes at t-minus seven
minutes we begin what we call engine
chill tree valves will open those
currently separate propellants on the
first stage from getting down to the
merlin engines will open the pre valves
that allow feel liquid oxygen to flow to
the top of the pumps and more
importantly when we open the valves that
allow us to begin chilling the nine
merlin 1d turbo pumps on the first stage
engine it'll take a few minutes to get
them cold enough to where they would
then be ready to pass the large amounts
of liquid oxygen through the pumps and
into the main thrust chambers when we
get to engine ignition at t-minus two
seconds we don't want to try to run
highly chilled liquid oxygen through a
warm pump you would flash that into gas
and running back to Ohio is not a good
thing
so right now we are waiting for t-minus
seven minutes that'll start the engine
chill shortly after that we will get the
feel shut down
listening to the SpaceX launch director
in the background there as I mentioned
at t-minus seven minutes as we start to
chill we will also get into the final
topping off of stage one feel and then
the fuel load will complete
so stage 1 and stage 2 engine chill has
started we've heard the call-out
Stage one engine chill has started
that's gone up to the career so that
they've got situational awareness as I
mentioned the free vowels are open and
now we are topping off first stage feel
getting ready to finish the fuel load
liquid oxygen load on first and second
stage will continue until the last three
to two minutes of the countdown we
should hear that call out our p1 load
complete coming up in about six minutes
again our p1 is just that densified
kerosene or that rocket fuel that Falcon
9 is gonna be used to power Bob and Doug
to orbit today and stage 1 fuel is quote
that right on time that call out
indicates that the feel loading on the
first stage is complete
draining back the lines now so first
stage and second stage feel our complete
liquid oxygen loading is continuing on
both stages you can see on the view on
the left side of monitor the
condensation the cold gas wrapped around
the stages is the tank skins are chilled
by the densified liquid oxygen picking
up the humidity from our Florida or it
looks like at this moment we're a little
more than 90 percent full on the
oxidizer on the first age ticking up
towards that eighty percent mark on the
second stage we'll be counting down all
the way till about two or three minutes
as John I just said until everything is
looking on heaters those note and then
we will be go for launch
dragon has transition to configure for
terminal count vehicle tanks pressing
for strong back detract
repressurizing the Falcon 9 tanks we're
going to open the clamp arm around the
second stage and begin to retract the
strong back we'll move back about two
degrees that'll get us to the liftoff
position at liftoff the strong rack will
then recline about 45 we just rode it
staged to our viewing bleed
launch director called out the strong
back retract has started on the left
you'll see it go back just a couple of
degrees page one apparently
we are just four minutes away from
liftoff I got at this moment Bob and
Doug are really just laser focused on
those displays they have insight
directly into dragon in the Falcon 9
they're able to see where their fuel
loading is that how everything's
progressing down with the count they
appear final set up started three and a
half minutes from launch and the strong
back is now reclining away from the
Falcon nine
I'm back igniter purges oh they'll
believe dragon has transitioned through
terminal count and his own internal pill
page one lock load close that okay we're
t-minus two minutes 42 seconds Stage one
locks load is closed out Stage two will
continue to load for about another half
a minute or so once we get the
completion of stage two locks loading we
have to vent down the line so you'll see
another large white cloud coming off of
the strong rack that'll be normal
that'll happen transitioning - one
minute and 40 seconds we're going on
internal power now just a few seconds
away from the stage - locks load being
complete it's been almost nine years
since we've been in this position a lot
of work done by thousands of people to
get to this point all our eyes focused
on - now
Stage two locks Lotus closed out
propellant pills are complete dragon is
an auto Idol stage two locks
loadcomplete
all fuel all oxidize are on Falcon nine
one minute thirty four seconds to go
till launch brown gas close I was
starting
Falcon 9 isn't startup dragon isn't
countdown FPS is armed for launch
under a minute now the FTS the flight
termination system has been armed dragon
spacex go for launch
SpaceX dragon we're go for launch
let's light this candle t-minus 30
seconds
Stage one thanks pressing for plate
t-minus 15 seconds 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
so rise not a new era of American space
flight day for both of the motivations
of a new generation continuing the dream
20 seconds into flight stage 1
propulsion is nominal flying crew on
board dragon at Falcon 9
look at him go Falcon power time to
nominal and one deed throttle down
we're throttling down to get ready for
the period of maximum dynamic pressure
we're in the throttle bucket
reports say all systems are go vehicle
is supersonic we've exceeded Mach 1 on
the Falcon 9 and what do you thought
elope we're throttling back up the full
pours with roommates to copy Juan Bravo
and we heard that one Bravo call-out
that's just the second aboard zone that
their end they'll continue to be on this
until the first age has done its job and
they switch over to the second at this
point Bob & Doug pulling about 2.3 G's
2.3 times the Earth's gravity already
flirting over 1,500 miles per hour we've
heard the call out for EM back engine
chill that's giving the M back engine
ready to light that will come at about
two forty four in the flight right now
everything continuing to look good next
major event coming up is going to be the
triple we'll have main engine cutoff of
the nine first stage engines stage
separation and then ignition of the
second stage engine to continue to carry
astronauts into orbit coming up in about
20 second m1d throttle down we heard
we're throttling down the merlin engines
on the first stage
and we have make out because Dawkins
their separation confirmed and BEC
ignition all right we have stage
separation confirm the first stage
beginning its flight back the second
stage being powered by that single
merlin 1d vacuum engine has ignited and
this battleship secretary Bob and Doug
into orbit so they're gonna continue
under the power of this second stage is
repulsion is nominal which will cut off
at Seco or second engine cut off at
about eight minutes and 44 seconds into
today's flight so a little over five
minutes to go still on this second stage
you're the call out to alpha so they're
now in the longest abort zone that
carries them all the way from about
North Carolina up the eastern seaboard
almost to Canada things looking good
though getting good call-outs not for
propulsion on that second stage bobbing
up continuing to make their way into
orbit
dragon SpaceX nominal trajectory boys
channel signal Bermuda thang dragon
nominal trajectory all right here in
nominal trajectory so dragon pointed in
the right direction continuing to make
their flight uphill hurt acquisition of
signal Bermuda that's one of the other
ground stations that they're using to
get telemetry and data back from this
space propulsion is still nominal
you
a little over four minutes 40 seconds
into the flight Bob & Doug flying at
more than 5,600 miles rectory already
almost 200 miles downrange from the
Kennedy Space Center nominal trajectory
continuing
and while they continue up it looks like
we are getting a view of the first age
as well if on your right screen you can
see that first stage with the grid fins
deployed it's making its way back to
attempt to land on our drone ship of
course I still love you today we're just
about a minute a couple minutes away
from the entry burn and that's where
three of the nine Merlin engines do
ignite to help slow the vehicle down as
it re-enters back into the Earth's
atmosphere and then after the entry burn
will be the landing burn which is just a
single engine SpaceX and orbital
trajectory and you heard I'm starting to
as I call out they are still on a
nominal trajectory on dragon still on
second stage and that's that M back
engine on second stage on your left
screen again on your right screen is
that first stage booster coming back
towards our drone ship of course I still
love you we're about a minute away from
entry burn meanwhile that second stage
continuing to power dragon into orbit
and if you're keeping an eye on that
timer that's gonna continue to burn
until 8 minutes and 44 seconds into
flight so a little over two minutes from
now we'll hear the call out Seco it will
then be a little overboard a little bit
a little over three minutes until dragon
physically separates from the second
stage of the Falcon 9 after the
everybody but I can Pat me down the
upper deck during continuing to check in
with Bob and Doug as they are on a
nominal trajectory just about 10 seconds
away from that first stage starting that
entry burn on your right screen we
should be able to see that view live
Stage one metric burn starter
and there is that entry burn beginning
on this burn lasts about 36 seconds long
stage 2 FPS is saved
well that entry burn continues for just
about a minute away from Seco we'll have
a number of events all happen in rapid
succession the second engine cutoff it
wouldn't be lunch before that stage one
landing burn shortly after actually just
within a few seconds of each other it's
such a cool view on your left screen
seeing Bob and Doug on dragon right now
you can see the displays that they are
seeing right now than Center little
guidance I'm back there although we are
coming up
25 seconds or so away from Seco or
second engine cutoff this is also the
point where Bob and Doug are
experiencing their highest g-force for
seeing the counter tick up to write
about your morning coffee Shannon you
heard Shannon so that just means they're
in their final abort zones if they were
to abort at this point but either being
abort to orbit or to land off the coast
of Ireland standing by for second one
line of confirmation and back Darla step
and back shutdown they join Lennie where
affirmation of Seco second engine cutoff
now we are waiting for our first stage
to make its way to our drone ship of
course I still love you I can stay sex a
little a little insertion justice what
you're seeing on your screen is a live
view of our drone ship where our first
stage will be coming down looks like we
lost that live view but wait for
confirmation of that landing shortly
here dr9 first a successful life and
there you can see on your screen
Falcon 9 has
this is the first falcon 9 to carry to
orbit so very exciting for us and as you
can see on your right screen Bob and
Doug are still making their way to their
targeted orbits near everyone so
exciting today it doesn't stop it does
not stop all right we did we did here
again that call-out good orbital
insertion so that means Falcon 9 and
dragon right now exactly where they're
supposed to be can we need a FRC on arc
everyone and it's right at about 12
minutes when dragon will separate looks
like we saw a zero-g indicator floating
around there I know Bob and Doug Oh us a
little bit about what exactly that is
that they brought up with them and
before separation before dragon initiate
separation from the second stage they do
make sure to make they do ensure that
the vehicle is not spinning and it is in
good condition before we separate that's
right the upper stage does small
attitude maneuver using cold gas
thrusters built into the rocket body
itself exactly so we do expect that
separation to occur in about a minute
from now but they do wait until they
have full confirmation that it is ready
to separate such cool views I cannot get
over this view that we are seeing right
now Bob and Doug on the right screen
inside of crew dragon out in space yeah
already 200 kilometers over planet earth
or a little over 124 miles traveling in
excess of 2700 meters
27,000 meters per second or about 16,000
miles per hour
again we're just standing by that
separation event should be coming up
shortly and they'll begin a series of
checks on the Draco thrusters that are
going to be used to maneuver and then
power dragon on its flight to the
International Space Station standing by
for separation expected losses signal
walls it sounds like we hadn't expected
l OS lost a signal with one of the
ground stations waiting for confirmation
now of that struggling separation
confirmed dragon separation confirms
there is a great view right in front of
you and there's that call out dragon is
now officially making its way to the
International Space Station today dragon
SpaceX with that separation call we have
a few words for you from our Falcon 19
by dragon chief engineer on dragon the
ground
Bob Doug on behalf of the entire launch
team thanks for flying with Falcon 9
today we hope you enjoyed the ride and
wish you a great mission thanks Paula
congratulations to you and the f9 team
for the first human ride for Falcon 9
and it was incredible appreciate all the
hard work and thanks for the great rides
of space wo wow I like it it proud of
you guys and the rest of the team thank
you so much for what you have done for
us today putting America back into
low-earth orbit I perform the Florida
coast
like Godspeed
all right so Bob and Doug are in nominal
eCos activation and serious section
Draco checkouts nosecone deploys in
progress
yeah pl
we're monitoring the core here in
Hawthorne giving the crew a heads up
that we have confirmation the nose cone
is deploying so again that nose cone is
going to open up a little bit more than
90 degrees goes up to about I think 105
degrees and that's gonna expose the
actual docking ring and the hatch that
they're gonna be going through once they
attach to the International Space
Station and also four of those Draco
thrusters become the forward bulkhead
thrusters they're gonna be used for
these major phase burns or firings of
those thrusters to actually raise their
orbit gradually over the coming hours
also heard good activation of the
Eclipse that's the environmental control
and life support system that's
everything controlling their atmosphere
just keeping drag in a nice safe
habitable environment where they're
gonna be living for the next 19 hours
until they arrive at the space station
right exactly and Falcon nines job may
be done for it's a day but the mission
is not over crew dragons job is not done
as you can see Bob and Doug are still
inside crew dragon making their way it
will be a 19-hour trip to the
International Space Station before they
dock tomorrow morning in such cool views
I love that we can get these live views
here and see and watch what they're
doing now that they are in orbit it's
incredible just be looking over their
shoulder to be along for the ride and
we're gonna be with them and we're gonna
be with all of you the entire way for
their journey to the space station we're
gonna be covering live throughout Bob
and Doug will obviously have a sleep
period where they'll get about eight
hours of sleep a little bit later today
before they wake up for all their final
approach one of the major things we are
looking forward to in the next couple of
hours is going to be their first turn at
the controls so they're actually going
to be
using those touchscreen displays to take
control and manually pilot dragon will
walk you through what that's going to
look like and assuming we have some good
ground station coverage we'll be able to
get views from right inside dragon
looking over their shoulder as they
manipulate the controls at the display
but I mean if we had a smooth ride
uphill both stages of the Falcon nine
doing their job placing Bob and Doug in
orbit I mean this is this is a day this
is a historical day this is us kicking
off that new era of spaceflight that
we've all been talking about and longing
for since the space shuttle program came
to an end in 2011 yeah the weather the
weather cooperated yes second time's a
charm
all right so Dave for the history book
books as you can see we have a lost some
live signal there but the mission still
continues and we're going to send it
over to KSC to continue broadcasting
live with them also you know the
excellent yeah Jesse and Dan we are just
in awe over here and I woke up this
morning and looked at the weather
forecast I was like man we're gonna be
back here on Sunday but we we did it and
the room cleared out everybody was
outside watching and then and inside the
lights were shaking the cameras were
shaking Lauren came back in with tears
in her eyes this is really amazing I I
can't believe it I thought with my own
eyes this is I'm a little bit speechless
um just so grateful that we got them
up there and there's a lot more to go a
lot more to go but I'm so happy they're
safe right now I'm just so happy yeah
Leland you were talking about it it's
amazing what we can do when we work
together yes American astronauts of an
American rocket from American soil
showing you what Americans can do when
we come together as a team and blast
Doug and Bob off to the cosmos this is
this is what it's all about and their
families and everyone is working
together to take them off the space
safely so I'm I don't know what to say
we want to go over to Darrell at OSP to
the he's there with the administrator
who hopefully has more words than we do
because we're still kind of speechless
Darrell incredible here Murray at the
Operations Support Building where a
chorus of applause has been happening
from the beginning of launch and
throughout the various stages some very
special guests were here to watch it
that includes President Donald Trump
vice president Mike Pence and NASA
Administrator Jim Brian Stein who joins
me now and you were with the president
and the vice president America's back
launching human astronauts again tell me
how you feel about that and tell me
about the president watching launch and
what happened then so this has been a
long time coming it's been nine years
since we've launched American astronauts
on American Rockets from American soil
and now it's done we have done it it's
been way too long I want to give a lot
of credit to Charlie Bolden he was my
predecessor as the NASA Administrator he
fought hard for this program at a time
when it didn't get any any support in
Congress we now have an administration
that is fully supportive of our
spaceflight initiatives not just on the
exploration discovery going to the moon
onto Mars but also from a space force
perspective our budgets are going up
things were strong and today was just it
was a just an amazing day you know one
of the things the president did right
out of the gate when he became president
is he created what's called the National
Space Council and he put the Vice
President as chairman of the National
Space Council and on that national space
Council you've got the Secretary of
Defense and the Secretary of State and
the Secretary of Commerce the Secretary
of Transportation the Secretary of
Education the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs all of these different amazing
individuals that deal with space day in
and day out a lot of people don't
realize how many parts of the federal
government deal with space and the vice
president invited those members of the
national space Council here as well so
we just had and then we had members of
Congress bipartisan members of Congress
Republicans and Democrats who have been
involved in supporting this program you
know for a long time now so I'll just
tell you I
I'm breathing a sigh of relief but I
will also tell you I am NOT going to
celebrate until Bob and Doug are home
safely tomorrow they're going to dock to
the International Space Station tonight
I'm heading to Houston to be at the the
Johnson Space Center when that happens
so it is it is a bit it's a bit of a
relief that the nosecone is now open
it's now deployed which means that you
know now we're going to go into some
some burns we're going to have some
phasing burns we're going to have some
some you know boosting burns and we're
going to get as much as we can in
alignment with the International Space
Station as early as possible here but
also I know it's hard but you know the
big thing that we need to do now is
we've got to get Bob and Doug who have
now gone through this exercise twice
they need to get some rest but I can
guarantee you there will be no rest for
a good good amount of time while they're
up there in orbit and they are certainly
on their way and a lot of people joining
us for